all right everybody and welcome to the
first speed Chess Championship Match
Anna we are
live uh you're muted
Anna so we can see your lips moving you
can try to read my lips all right the
games will be starting in language the
games will be starting in everybody I
would just saying that I'm really
excited for this match between Hikaru
and Sergey Nakamura versus Gregorian the
first match of the Spees Championship
2017 we all are and uh we we were unable
to go to go live a little early with
some pregame but let's just go over some
stuff real quick because the first few
games will have a slower time control
afford us a little bit of of talking and
set the tone for these two but these two
have played each other many many times
on our site Anna we actually have some
stats here uh take a guess how many
times these two have played each other
on chess.com
um 76
that's a pretty good guess actually um
is
it yeah it's I I actually don't even
have the total number but uh the stats
we have when these two are matching up
in Blitz or bullet on chess.com when
Nakamura is white he has 26 wins five
draws and six losses when he's black he
has 23 wins eight draws and six losses
so on paper we're thinking okay this is
obviously a matchup that that seems to
to favor Nakamura but recently and some
of the titled player the title Tuesday
qualifiers uh which took place during
the entire month of April uh Sergey was
probably the most active uh he I think
he played in all four uh he was our
first qualifier Anna and and I I brought
up the game here where they played each
other last time where Sergey as black
actually missed a win um he yes he had a
queen versus rook and Bishop and he went
for the repetition of moves um I think
out of respect so when you face Hikaru
you might think that a draw is enough um
he could have probably played for a draw
play for a win by playing King H6 that's
right if he had played King H6 uh it
looks like there was a way out without
getting the king made it of course he
was worried about threats of G5 check
and Rook takes H7 but there was a way
out um and but instead he took a draw so
just setting the tone that recently
these guys have been on a on a on a more
equal footing despite the huge uh
favorite that H carore is coming in and
on that note let's jump right into the
games both players are already focused
because as we were describing their last
encounter they are creating a new
encounter uh and we have a very equal
position currently on the board um
the reminder of the format for everybody
we're we're talking about a a format
that goes from 5 minutes and and the 2
second increment to 3-2 then 1 one and
uh and and bullet after that I'm uh I'm
actually resetting our our overall timer
right now MH um and uh we have we have
liftoff in regards to the total game
clock running down which means we have
90 minutes of 5 minute chess and and the
games have begun so what do we see right
here uh Serge Sergey gets white in the
first game and currently maybe has a
small Edge in this very equal
position yes I like his position it's a
it's a position that you play either for
a win or a draw I mean there are two two
options he can barely lose this game
unless it's Blitz and we are talking
about Blitz game so in a classical chess
game I would say that this is a very
safe opening for white you can never
lose this in blades uh anything can
happen but of course this is the longest
Blitz game so for 90 minutes they will
be playing with five minutes plus 2
second increment and then we will switch
to shter time
controls that's right and and the reason
why Anna talks about the position being
difficult for white to lose is because
from a you look at usually what these
players need to outplay the other as
some sort of Target to to develop a plan
of some kind and gang up on some sort of
weakness but in this case you have a
structure where both sides have
essentially no weaknesses both sides
have pawns that are almost exactly the
same uh besides this this A3 and uh and
B6 pawns being slightly different so I
if if you don't have those sort of
long-term targets to play for you're
really relying on on peace activity and
the initiative which normally players of
this level calculate accurately and so
they're not going to blunder peace
tactics so for for players of a beginner
level sometimes wonder why we look at
positions so equal and think oh this is
just this is just kind of boring or a
draw but that's part of the reason is
you know players of that level don't
normally blunder unless there's some
sort of weakness or issue in their
position that they're struggling to
defend um Hikaru is is focused right now
it's one of those rare times we may see
throughout this entire match andna hiar
Nakamura is actually down on time if you
look at his his uh his facial expression
he's clearly focused in on uh trying to
maybe develop a plan to maybe mix things
up here and here he goes with Knight H5
uh with an attempt to maybe win the
bishop
here yeah the this is clearly a warm-up
game so both players are still very slow
and they are trying to to figure out
what the opponent wants in terms of
preparation as well because they will be
playing so many games against each other
and they should have prepared an opening
rep aror just for this match so we will
see what that is they had two days to
prepare for this match actually that's
not a long time yeah and I wonder we we
used to do pregame interviews with these
things but we found over time as uh as
the high level players got more involved
that they're not really used to pregame
interviews they don't do that at any
other super grandmas tournaments it's
difficult for them to reveal Secrets
before the actual match but we we will
get to those questions afterwards it's
always nice to ask did you do any
preparation what was it and how did you
feel you faced or you matched up what
was what was the time control you
thought you might do better and of
course hindsight is always 2020 and uh
for the loser they might say Oh I
thought I was going to do well in 3-2
but it you know turns out they got
killed or something so things things
change depending on what actually
happens but uh what's happening here I
think Nakamura is probably going to look
for a plan where he brings his King out
to E7 I was expecting King F King E7 as
well to bring the king he went B5
because I think he was afraid of Knight
A4 and in fact that was an annoying
threat Knight A4 and then jumping to B6
with the Knight or Knight C5 as well so
he prevented that with B5 now the
question is can white improve his
position and he's going for Knight
D4 got it
okay a small update being done here to
the total to the total uh game clock
everyone will notice that it just jumped
down a little bit because we have the
exact the exact uh game clock running in
case as I'm hosting the show technical
errors happen as as we saw with some
with some stuff happen happing to start
the match so my the official Arbiter of
these events who keeps track of all
those details uh Mr Pete our our senior
editor in events manager on chess.com
informed me that uh informed me at the
exact right time to set the clock to
1:23 so now the time you see is exactly
and correct the time remaining in this
control um Sergey looks like he's doing
well here a bishop to F3 is a
interesting move there's immediately
tactics here and I'm looking at Knight
takes C3 because after Bishop takes B7
we have a check on E2
uh both sides going on with that Knight
takes C3 he hiar didn't go for it he
went King f f very quickly and I think
the reason is at the end of this line hi
Caro calculated quickly he would be
dealing with a double attack with both
the Knight and the pawn Under Fire it
would not have been a good idea for for
him to do that so instead uh hikaro
actually wait a second he did go for
it I thought he won Bishop uh after
Bishop F3 he won King f8
eight huh so I I've gone back to the
game and uh we have uh we have an issue
here a technical issue I will I will try
to refresh and then see what's going
on um they just played King f8 King F1
both of them bringing the
king okay well that that's good now I
now I I'm back on the board
um
all right well um we are now able to
look at the live position and and we
hope I hope that that that bug does not
continue there all right so what do we
see here is is the issue that black has
is he giving up the D5 Pawn for a chance
to get the second rank it seems to be
the case and Sergey doesn't want it he
plays King to E1 I think the risk he
just the yeah he thinks that he can do
it anytime so he's bring he's activating
his King first and since Hikaru cannot
unpin this Knight on D5 uh he's just
waiting for the right moment to take on
D5 I believe right no that makes sense
and then that's a good lesson for
everybody patience being a virtue here
for for white the point is that if you
you know if if you capture too early in
a lot of these positions and go for it
black will black will get plenty of
compensation for the pawn a rook on the
seventh rank might be might be more than
white bargain for so um now I go back to
the main game and uh unfortunately I
once again do not see the position so
I'm going to have to avoid doing that
kind of
analysis um but okay so let let's take a
look at what the what's going on with
the players
here yes Serge is going down on the
clock so he's under one minute well 1
minute 2 seconds now with the increment
he was thinking a lot about this King d2
move move and um I can understand it
because you feel like with what you have
a slight advantage and you want to
increase this Advantage by progressing
the fact is that it's not so easy to do
anything in this position so black
cannot bring his King to the D5 because
of the pin that would be E4 winning the
Knight on D5 um but anything else could
be just a normal waiting move for black
now the question is yeah whether he can
play for something else and this is what
iaru is doing he's not just waiting but
he goes for A5 with a potential B4
though when you push B4 I can still
capture on B4 and then on D5 so I don't
think that black can do much here but he
should just wait yeah and he probably
still has a good chance to draw I mean
as we look at time the the one of the
first things we observed that hikara was
down on time is no longer the case and
if we had and do a rook ending that's
that's likely where uh the the yeah he's
dropping the pawn he's dropping the B5
Pawn that's why uh Serge took on D5 in
the right moment and pushed B4 yeah
absolutely and hikaro is hikaro was
focused here I mean obviously he knows
uh he knows he's under the gun here it's
only the first game but you can tell
he's he's very relaxed uh well you can
tell that Serge is very relaxed usually
when hikaro is feeling more confident we
see a little bit of a headbob right we
see a little bit of a look into the sky
usually he feels very comfortable
calculating there but when he looks like
this usually it means he's really feels
like he's needs to buckle
down yeah yeah um I was wrong with the
Knight T B5 move because the G2 Pawn was
hanging I I forgot about that so there
was no way of winning a pawn not even on
taking uh on D5 so this is an equal
position uh but I think they will still
play no they will not maybe I shouldn't
predict they agreed in a
draw so this was a warm up game uh I
think both players are still trying to
to figure out how uh how their opponent
is in terms of uh aggressive uh how
aggressive they want to play what
opening reper are they prepared for the
match and uh we are looking forward to
these hours of Blitz and bullet between
the two players so this was just the
beginning it's going to be more exciting
in the coming games I'm sure about that
yeah well now hikaro gets the white
people is obviously is the uh favorite
higher rated opponent um he he wants to
win every game but the Troth is getting
black to start and you kind of easing
into the match flow I don't think a draw
is the is the worst result there but we
have a draw and now Nakamura will get
the white
pieces uh and
uh and we'll see uh we'll see how he
tries to attack so we have a weird Kings
Indian attack here uh
the the what so one of the things that's
funny about this position is so black
gets this big Center Pawn structure
which normally would be conducive to
attacking on the king side because when
you have a big a big space Advantage
facing a certain direction everybody uh
usually that that affords you to bring
pieces aggressively to that side but
when you're going against a king side
that's fan ketto White's King side is
usually very safe with the bishop in
front of it uh and um so likely this is
not going to be a position where black
gets to get a big attack and so white I
think white has the upper hand probably
something like Queen to B3 comes in here
and look for white to strive for F3 at
some point to to open up the diagonal
and then get a bunch of pieces ganging
up on the D5 Pawn if
possible yeah we are also receiving some
very interesting facts uh thanks to Mike
thank you Mike for all these updates
he's saying that he car played the Kings
Indian attack pretty much during one
match of the blitz battle last year so
this is his goto opening in Blitz yeah
it was almost exclusive which match was
that it was it was the yeah I'm trying
to it was the first match it wasn't it
wasn't the match with mvl or Carlson I
believe but but I'm trying to remember
who he was playing was that then pentala
pentala har Krishna I'm not sure I'm not
sure actually yeah so so this position
is is interesting I mean the main issue
for black is is that you know this D5
Pawn which normally is kind of an anchor
to help you to be aggressive uh when you
have a closed Pawn structure it's it's
really just much more of a Target here
um and so so black is going to do
everything he can maybe use the C file
uh but but if white is able to open up
the bishop pair here you'll get two
Bishops rolling and and maybe the white
the white squared Bishop will have some
Targets on D5 so I think White's better
here judging by hikaru's kind of
reaction I did see a little hikaro look
off to the to the right that usually
means he's
um this is
uh if you look up to the right that what
does that mean inspiration he's
confident it's it's like it's just you
know I understand I speak fluent Hikaru
facial expressions and and usually
usually you can tell by how he feels
about the position by how he looks so I
think he's one of the more emotional uh
he wears his emotions really on his on
his sleeve and I think you kind of know
how he feels usually by how he looks
so I agree with you I think he is the
new Gary Kasparov in this
sense yeah Kasparov also famous for that
right you kind of knew how he felt and
although some people felt like you
didn't really know how he felt and it
was all just kind of a psychological
game but uh but yeah so all right well
uh again if you're just joining us uh or
if you've been here for the whole time
thank you for being here the whole time
and everybody who's been following and
and subscribing to our Channel thank you
for doing that so many of you doing that
right now and if you're just joining us
and wondering what this is again
remember this is the this is the speed
Chess Championship this will be the
biggest event happening in the online
chess world for the remainder of 2017
every one of the players you see before
you now will be competing in one match
or another uh the first one of course we
see here right now happening between
Nakamura and gregorians uh the three in
the 14 seed uh $50,000 at stake a lot of
total prize money for just a few hours
of Blitz a couple times and um make sure
you you stay tuned obviously you can
follow who wins and and when the next
matches are the next match actually on
the schedule is May 24th with Sergey
carakan versus gorg Meyer followed
immediately by uh the first I think the
first real the first two seeded players
match right we have so and Anish giri
going on just the next day on May
25th yeah this is going to be epic I I
think whether it's Magnus or Hikaru of
course they are the two players that are
the most likely to get to the finals but
even if they get to the finals it won't
be an easy ride yeah no there's and uh
there's many more top players than there
was in our first year last year so
interested to see how those matches play
out so uh Sergey defending really well
here doesn't look like AAR was able to
get he wasn't able to get the plan I was
kind of suggesting and obviously I think
one of the biggest risks behind F3
everybody as far as where you would
normally do it is that it uh it would
would have been more weakening to
White's King side right and normally
that pawn on H2 guarding G3 would afford
white to be a little more aggressive
with F3 and try to pry things open but
white really couldn't do that despite
how much he wants this bishop to be in
the game because the G3 Pawn would be
falling in a lot of lines and so so that
that kind of saved gregorians from being
a little worse in these positions I
think yeah I think he uh I agree with
you that he's defending very well now
the question is after the trade of
Queens um now it's easier to push F3 he
went G4 hearon G4 and now F3 so he wants
to win this end game thanks to the pair
of Bishops and Sergey has to try to keep
the position as closed as possible if
this long diagonal opens up for the G2
Bishop then that will be trouble so so
he has to find Counterattack now he is
targeting the D4 Pawn
immediately
yep is hikaro still with us I don't know
that he
is I don't know who he is his moves but
I don't see his face anymore I see his
moves as well I think he I'm not sure
he's aware aware that he dropped out
having some small technical difficulties
here I
apologize oh he's back he's back there
he is I think he wasn't aware that he uh
that he dropped out there and and so we
move back to the four cameras we can see
uh Sergey crouched in very focused hiar
a little more relaxed right now uh
leaning leaning back and
um maybe maybe both side still kind of
just feels like everyone's just easing
into this right now and it feels like
maybe it's our maybe it's cuz I'm so
distracted with the technical
difficulties and whatever but it feels
like the match really hasn't even
started yet uh this is this is still the
very beginning so still warming up but I
feel like Hikaru is already more into
the match and I think he's going to win
this game because he has managed to open
the position for the Bishops and the
problem for black is that you can't move
the knights you cannot maneuver nice to
anywhere where they would be more useful
because the pawns the B7 and the A7
pawns will be hanging so he's trying of
course he has to try but it's not easy
to move move those Knights away from the
queen
side yeah it is and this is exactly the
kind of position or the kind of end game
where we where we hear all those phrases
I think uh the bishop and Knight are
worth three points right when players
first learn chess and then they learn
over time like why do people think the
Bishops are better well it's because
most of the time positions eventually
become open and then you see the Bishops
really get active in this way now now
black doesn't have any permanent
weaknesses an know yes these pawns are
Under Fire but you know without some
sort of concrete plan to pry pry openen
the position further black isn't black
isn't hurting in terms of a long-term
weakness right there's no isolated pawns
there's no double pawns so this is this
still isn't going to be easy yet for
Nakamura to convert on the endgame
Advantage despite despite the two
Bishops being very good here yeah now
this Knight D4 is really annoying I
think because after Bishop takes D4 you
have to take care of the king side
suddenly so it's not only about the
queen side pawns
anymore yeah well so now now the
question is where's the the second
weakness right normally when you have
Targets on one side of the board you got
to find some way to make your opponent's
life difficult so I would imagine hikaro
will probably continue some sort of
clamp over here on the queen side and
then maybe in a perfect world he might
even try to walk the king up and now
here he comes with it but I don't see an
exact way in but obviously if you get
the more active King here that ALS Al
would greatly increase chances wh's
chances to win this same
game yeah it's not easy but I have the
feeling that he will manage now he's
activating his King and he should find a
way to open the somehow H4 G5 in the
right moment if he could go for that and
uh grab the G7 Pawn although even if he
manages
to um somehow exchange pawns on the king
side there are just so few few pawns on
the board left that it might still be a
draw right and and you see ciry has set
up a blockade here everybody using the
Knight well whenever you have a knight
uh and a bishop so you you don't have
the bishop here but one Knight one
Bishop it's very very often the best
plan to put the Knight on the same color
as your Bishop so that it controls the
opposite color Square you'll notice like
in this last position here the Knight
and Bishop worked well together sort of
controlling each one of these squares
right preventing there from being any
sort of real access point for the white
king so that's an interesting thing to
note that you put your knight on the
same color as your bishop and that helps
you to keep a blockade the bishop
controlling one color Square your knight
controlling the opposite color Square
that's just good defensive endgame
technique uh and that's what is doing
fine and it was not an easy position to
defend with the Knights on C6 and B6 I
was really worried for him right but he
seems to have set up a bit of a wall
right now and uh and that's definitely
going to be difficult here and it looks
it's looking more and more like
like unable to break down here like
white is not going to be able to
um white is not going to be able to
break through
here yeah of course hiar will try and he
has lots of time he has two and a half
minutes versus 44 seconds so that is a
huge factor and maybe if this POS if
this game will be decided that will be
due to the time
Factor
right so s has has managed to maneuver
his Knight to E5 which is a progress and
now with the King on E6 that is once
again a blockade the white king cannot
go to F5 and then G6 thanks to these
pieces on E5 and E6 um which means that
Black's setup is an ideal
setup sometimes the problem can be if
you run out of moves and if there is a
tuwang like now he had to give up the F5
Square
um yeah he sacrificed the E3 Pawn
because because why I thought he wanted
to go Bishop G3 and take on E5 and then
G6 maybe it's s maybe it didn't
sacrifice maybe it didn't sa think he
wondered it maybe I mean okay I don't
think he can lose now and it looks like
the most concrete plan going for the
obso bishop ending is just going to lead
to a draw and uh hikaro turns his head
and scratches scratches because he's not
happy may he blundered it I want to say
here that was the key would he play King
to G6 instead and and go
after he sacrificed the pawn to right to
eliminate the Knight and then go King G6
but perhaps this was not his idea so
that was a draw and N guys once again uh
with the white
pieces so a little disappointment for
Hikaru because he had a very pleasant
position where he was uh putting
pressure on Sergey for the whole game
and now that sery managed to defend he's
got the psychological Edge yeah you know
it's got to feel really good obviously
when you're such a big Underdog playing
one of the you know the best Blitz and
bullet maybe the best online Blitz and
bullet player ever you just you kind of
want to stay in the in the game right
but you know I think one of the things
that if we were talking about this match
bigger picture we didn't have time for
pregame today everybody sorry about that
because of some of the technical issues
we were dealing with but you know
probably if you assessed every time
control we would anticipate that
Nakamura Advantage will increase with
every one of these time controls would
you agree with that yeah I think so I
think that will that is what we are
going to
see are they repeating the same opening
again yeah they are and it's an opening
again that you know leads to kind of the
structure we talked about right just all
symmetrical okay this is certainly going
to be a different move order here but
usually white just has a small edge here
so kind of if knowing the dynamic player
Nakamura is and and uh you know he's
he's the favorite I'm kind of surprised
going for this sort of um is it fair to
say lifeless or there's not a lot of
fight in this opening as as we said
before everybody when there's just no
weaknesses for either side uh it's just
it means all the action's going to
happen right here on the dile and uh and
if all the action is just about the
pieces either the D file or the C file
you get a lot of Trades and and then no
weaknesses so sort of strange stuff
there so far the choice by
Nakamura um thanks to Mike we have some
more stats on the match and he's saying
that only 12 of their 74 previous games
on chess.com were
draws and here they already started with
two draws they've already started with
two draws and Sergey finds this very
strong move actually I mean a bit
counterintuitive but also very heads up
white recognizes that with the early
advance of B5 we have two unprotected
minor as well after Rook to C1 you can't
really defend both in one move right if
you move the bishop and your hikaro then
there's going to be discovered attacks
here so iaro just kind of recognizes he
blundered I think after Bishop B7 what
exactly is happening on Knight takes B5
where white we shall see because Serge
went for it and this just seems a pawn
up it's a pawn up although there is a
small initiative now returning to Black
right because of white not being castled
okay now White Castles which is just
going to give back the pawn so perhaps
not Amora knew a little more about what
he was getting into but uh look at the
position if you captured the opp on A3
then after Rook B1 yeah problems because
of C6
Knight yeah so hikaro recognizes that
the point everybody is that if the Rook
got there the bishop would be under Fire
and would have you know big
responsibilties so hikaro has to play
accurately here if he's going to find
his way out of this when when it looks
like he's gotten himself in a bit of
trouble Stills like the initiative is
going his way though
right yeah why did he Place The Rook on
C4 and stepped into Bishop A6 or it's
not a big deal that he stepped into
it I mean he can take any of the knights
but his Bishop will be
captured yeah and now after this trade
hikaro will just I assume he'll take F3
and then gobble back no he can't because
of Bishop to D6 in the end aha skewer
double attack there of the of the two
Rooks so hikaro can take here but he
will still he will still have his work
cut out for him as far as when he can
take back this Pawn but look at that
move wow yeah that's trapping The Rook
that is amazing a surprise Rook trap in
the middle of the board right not sure
saw that one coming something very
rarely seen that The Rook on e4 is
trapped this way with just three
pieces Serge shaking his head a little
bit there for those who just saw we
brought the players back I think Sergey
has some drawing chances here um if he
can if he can hold on the A3 Pawn but
the more I look at it the more that
seems like it'll be unlikely and and
probably Nakamura is on Pace to notch
his first win
here yes this is certainly something
that Sergey missed that after Bishop
takes E2 Bishop takes F3 was the move
that he calculated and not Bishop D3
winning the winning the exchange
right well uh this is interesting so
what kind of drawing chances do you
think white has here maybe explain that
for everybody body oh well I don't think
he has much
because H I'm afraid that uh man that
black will manage to activate both of
his Rooks so a scenario where you can
double Rooks on the a file or even
double Rooks in the second Rank and I
think this is happening also the Light
Square Bishop of black is going to be
very dangerous if you place it for
instance on
e4 I think black will win this what do
you think Danny yeah well I mean as long
as you can hold on to the B4 Pawn
there's always chances because um you
know a pawn for the exchange is is uh is
helpful and and the other thing is white
doesn't have any other weaknesses other
than other than uh you know if the both
Rooks stayed on the board and they got
working together on the second rank for
example and they could create targets
but put it this way if the Rooks came
off the board right now and and you know
assume there was no matate tricks or
anything I'm I'm assuming that I think
white actually has excellent drawing
chances because there are no other Pawn
weaknesses and it's one of those
positions where um the two Rooks the two
Rooks are definitely better in this case
for black normally you you don't think
about it that way but in this case if if
black can keep the Rooks on the board I
think and create targets that's one
thing but otherwise I don't know okay
although now as I calculate concretely I
could be wrong based very simply on the
fact that there's a there's a concrete
threat coming here because of the first
rank issues yeah the back rank is the
real problem here Rook A1 threatening to
win a piece and I don't see a way out of
that because the back rank is weak so he
has to deal with the losing of the F1
Knight and also a back rank
mate yeah but okay so after F3 it looks
like white will be able to defend Rook
A1 the key line must be Rook A1 Bishop
F2 if trade and
takes Rook to A1 again the king comes to
f to so we're going to see that line I
mean hikaro is a little skeptical as you
can see from his facial expression
Sergey hoping that this defense is going
to work here um both of his pieces will
come under Fire on the first rank Anna
but after King F2 do we see a concrete
way that hikaro continues to convert I
don't know that we
do good question because if you give a
check on A2 after King F2 King can go
back to G1 and you are still protecting
the F1 Knight but I think this is uh
this is very suspicious this position
with two pieces on the back rank uh I I
would be very surprised if this can be
this can be protected somehow he will
lose material somehow that that looks
very strong actually Rook E2 creates
some serious some dysfunctional
questions everybody because now the
rook's going to come back I think to
B2 and yeah after threatening the PA but
mainly Rook
B1 Bishop B1 says that Bishop B1 holds
because the king F2 will be once again
after Rook B1 the only defense but but
as you said now now this there's been
such an improvement for black along the
way that now my prediction that if
everything came off it would be a draw I
was sort of you know anticipating that
white would have an active bishop and
protection of the pawn not a position
where his King was was completely cut
off on the second rank as it is here and
I think that uh Black is Black is going
to go on to win mainly because white is
frozen frozen solid here can't exactly
now this is I I believe this is
completely lost because of the fact that
black is controlling the b poor and he's
cutting the King on the second rank I
see that Robert Is Here Robert has in
the chat and he's saying trade all and
move the king in so yeah I I agree that
that is the winning plan so thank you
Robert for for helping us out with the
commentary and shout out to everybody
here on chess.com in the chat I'm
following whatever you guys are saying
I'm trying to have eyes on everything
awesome and you can also get at us on
Twitter Anna usually follows that as
well we both try to we see a couple of
hashtags there hashtag chest TV #p chess
exactly there are some new tweets using
the hashtag spe chess so keep them
coming on Twitter as well hashtag spe
chess talk about the Nakamura gregorians
match the first match of the spe
Championship
2017 and it looks like we are headed
toward our first our first win here
right it's uh it's the first time
somebody gets hit is when the match
starts right right before this we had a
couple of draws and now likely Nakamura
converts on this position um although
the more pawns come off the board the
harder it gets so we we'll see how he
converts on this but um assuming he does
an know we're looking at a scenario
where he then gets the white pieces and
the first time gregorians is really
under pressure as the underdog in the
match yeah he's going down in this game
that is almost sure uh luckily for him
there are so many games to come very
nice move there everybody oh no it
doesn't quite win on the spot but the
point everybody was black was sort of
trying to put white in a zigong uh
taking away moves from the King and and
forcing the bishop to move uh but but
still I mean as much as we've as we've
been saying it'll convert I mean with
without I I you know I'm still yet to
see I don't have a winning plan in my
mind yes I can say generally like others
okay The Rook is dominant here the king
is active but I don't I don't see a
winning plan for black yet so I would
love to be educated on that um from
either one of our many Grand Masters
hanging out in the chat or uh or saying
a winning
Planet it doesn't look like there is a a
win right now at this moment but I would
say that if you bring the king to F1 and
then the Rook to the second rank then
that's a win and I don't see how you
prevent that the question is you can
prevent it by attacking the king Side PA
right the question is can you get there
can can the black king get in one of
these positions without these Pawns
becoming uh the big story right the H4
and G5 pawns are stuck on dark squares
which makes this bishop a very useful
piece um so aaro is going to try to do a
couple of things one of them is to get
his opponent under time pressure and
this is how the chess games are
sometimes won right you put the pressure
on your opponent in a way that uh in a
way that is is both practical and
Technical right when you don't have a
lot of time to think that's when people
make mistakes so here he goes hearo now
oh I thought he was going to go for your
plan Anna The Rook had come to a
protective Square
I'm surprised he didn't try to advance
his King
there yeah that's that's slightly
surprising but what we'll see I think is
just um moving back and forth because
Hikaru has so much time on the clock
that he he can simply make sery defend
this position forever so now he has
traded on
G4 the the threat now everybody that
that the King has reached G4 is say if
black gets an ideal position with the
Rook maybe behind the pawn and on the
second rank you're going to see threats
of H3 where the uh where the white Pawn
is pinned but but Sergey is I mean this
is this given that given that he's been
worse in several of the games so far we
have to be really impressed with his
defensive technique I mean it is and
what is this
H3 H3 he just gave up the pawn and now
it's definitely a draw I mean even if
even if white was to give up the H Pawn
the the king is already in the ideal
Corner everybody uh a technical draw a
technical draw is when you have um I
don't understand why he car went for
this so quickly because maybe he had
nothing better but I thought that he
could have just maneuvered and
threatening basically the same threats
all the time with no time on the clock
for
Serge yeah also shout out to to
Grandmaster Max illingworth from
Australia and he saw all this uh coming
when Bishop A6 was played that the king
is in the right corner and it's a
defendable position for white it's very
interesting yeah so again as I was
trying to touch on there is the main
thing everybody is that if your king is
in the same color Corner as your Bishop
you're losing these end games with King
and Rook versus King and Bishop but the
problem here for for Nakamura is there's
no way to really make progress despite
how bad this looks for white without
stalemating white so now the Rook is
going to take the pawn and and really
you know other than the fact that Sergey
is under time pressure so could
potentially blunder uh there's really no
chance for black to win the game as
we're about to see if Rook D1 check the
bishop goes to G1 and there's no zigong
because white is Ste mated so this is a
good lesson I think many people don't
know they always hear rook and Bishop
versus Rook as king and Rook as a draw
but good to see it in practice and um
and as long as as long as white holds
this then all the defensive ADV advice
we're giving Will matter and I think
that Sergey will despite only a few
seconds on the
clock yeah Mike is saying that uh he
could have won this yesterday in the
title Tuesday tournament Rook versus uh
Knight was the position that he won and
now this is Rook versus
Bishop got
it well uh the uh it looks like we're
going to once again be in a position
where the score only goes only goes in
the direction of of another draw
everybody this is our third game if
you're just getting here welcome and
thanks for being here the uh 2017 speed
Chess Championship is underway with this
match Nakamura versus gregorians and um
all right we're four games in no blood
has been spilled yet which means
nobody's really been hit as Mike Tyson
would say everyone has a plan until you
get hit and uh in this case everybody's
still kind of following their plan or at
least if you're
so look at that that's that's a nice
finish yeah well uh now now we're
already moved on here to the next game
and
um and uh and okay so the another Kings
Indian attack by Hikaru and and we're
off and three drows so far the result
that was the least
likely if we look at the stats the games
between the two of them 74 games and
only 12 draws and now we are on to the
third draw but this is just the
beginning guys don't say that this is
going to be a boring match I'm pretty
sure that we will see blood and fire on
the board no no matches with AAR
Nakamura are ever that boring and and
here we see our first okay he's going in
for an attack uh Sergey is is about his
focused as Saro nakamura's last year
first round opponent right there was the
funny jokes made where uh pentala Hari
Krishna was so focused at a certain
point we thought his camera was frozen
cuz he wasn't even blinking uh but and
Sergey not you know he's he's moving a
little bit but still you know really
really zoned in here uh hikaro seems a
little stressed just from holding his
head in his hand there I think he's a
little frustrated by his inability to
convert on a couple advantages Anna but
but this one should be fun we have the
makings of a potential kingside attack
here everybody uh with this Pawn
structure hikaro is going to try for F4
at some point and really look to expand
and maybe create attacking chances on
the king
side I agree with you that this could be
the first decisive game at least at
least in terms of the opening and where
it is heading to this is going to be a
more exciting position I don't think
that we will see an end game now yeah
here comes F4 and and here comes what
the doctor ordered right everyone wants
a Win Regardless either hararo is going
to check made black or die trying and
that's what we want here and uh again
thank you everybody for being here
thanks to everybody who's who's uh
following and subscribing to our channel
for the first time make sure you pay
attention because uh chess is uh chess
is is here all the time at our at our
channel here on Twitch and for all those
members who already know that on chess
TV thanks for being here um all right
well these players are focused again
hikaro is has got his red wall behind
him other than his match with with
Carlson in the end he always had this
red wall behind him I felt like it made
him even more intimidating what do you
think Anna I agree with you red is an
intimidating color it's an aggressive
color and he seems to like it so that is
something that hikaro has chosen so far
for these matches on chess.com
I think we are seeing his home so that
must be maybe the living
room yeah it must be his home for those
who were here during the pregame they uh
may have even seen uh Serge Serge's wife
right uh Petra his fiance Petra his
fiance that's why I that's why I held
there I wasn't sure if it was official
yet but his fiance who's also your
teammate on the Hungarian national team
right that's why I know Sergey because
uh he seems to be dating my teammates
that's right well uh so she was she's
there somewhere um in their in their
house and we can see he's got some
degrees or some sort of pictures on the
wall behind him we'll pretend those are
like you know uh doctorates from you
know med school or something just you
know just makes makes it more fun all
right well Nakamura didn't fully convert
on that attack right a few moments ago
we saw a queen on G3 and a knight on F5
and you just start begging for mate but
that's not happening now but watch out
for the bishop and the here to to maybe
maybe get involved together in something
nasty um always be careful of a bishop
on that long diagonal uh Sergey from the
Soviet chess School Anna but he he's
he's broken a Russian school boy rule
with a knight on B6 in a couple games in
a row uh what do you say about that
that's true that's true that somehow he
likes to have the Knight on
B6 yeah and uh jokes aside I think it's
made sense in the in the structure but
uh now now we're headed toward a
position where okay hikaro seems to have
much more coordination than black I
expect him to avoid the queen trade
although he has to be careful of Rook to
D2 that's maybe why he declined it where
is this game headed and I like E5
actually now the Knight comes to E4 and
this bishop is involved what do you
think I like it um I'm a bit surprised
that the Queens are once again off of
the board and I said that it was not
going to head towards an end game but it
is true that the move E5 is with this
huge ambition of opening the long
diagonal Sergey took on E5 and that is a
good decision you cannot really let your
King on A8 be under the attack of the B2
Bishop but now what we see is a p Pawn
for right so that is the drawback of f
takes C5 yeah and this Knight on e4 this
is a tough decision yeah so Sergey plays
Bishop E7 to prevent Knight G5 what I
was just going to say um because the
tough decision is you never want to
leave your opponent with a beast like
that in the middle of the board but but
giving up the bishop pair was was
probably not a great idea either
um okay so now he's he's going to try to
try to unwind as best he
can I like that Sergey is activating his
pieces that we have seen Bishop H4 now
Knight D5 he's bringing his minor pieces
and you should really do your best
creating Counterattack when you're are
facing a pass Pawn like this one on
E5 yeah and Sergey has already defended
really well again if you're just joining
us everybody you can see by the score
that we are three games deep and no
blood shed yet just a bunch of draws and
I think we agree hikaro Nakamura was
pushing in a couple games but but
gregorian's defended very very well um
and and so he he's hoping to do that
again now although this one looks
tougher than any of them yet andna now
now the B7 Pawn is under Fire everybody
you can't move it because the bishop on
this diagonal so this is getting tougher
and tougher for black yeah as
suddenly suddenly this is unpleasant but
once again Bishop B7 and you have to
move the Rook away from from B4 now
targeting the A7 Pawn this is an
annoying position for black but I feel
like Ser is still defending very well
yeah no I agree a lot of Acura moves and
he's he's down on time one of the things
that is almost never surprising we're
surprised whenever Nakamura is down on
time so a car bring up a minute here is
not that surprising and we've already
seen Sergey defend a few games with only
a few seconds on the clock so uh but but
we know that the every draw that happens
Anna the more impatient uh the the top
player Nakamura will become right we
know that right now he's already been
shuffling in his chair a little bit so
we we'll bring back the player view he's
he's uh he's looking to to do something
nasty with this H Pawn and and we came
back just in time to see Sergey kind of
shake his head um for the record
everybody cap in that sense this match
reminds me of the world championship
match in New York because I feel like
this is Sergey has a similar sty to the
other Sergey Sergey kakin and I also
feel like Hikaru could could be
frustrated by not winning those
advantages that he had in the previous
game so who knows where this match will
head to still though now with the
kingside open this Rook on the fourth
rank seems to have some potentially
nasty intentions I I'm anticipating this
one will be the first win for the
American because you mentioned uh the
other Sergey let's go ahead and bring up
um a quick reminder because so many
viewers have now come in we have so many
new people here the next match for the
speed chest Championship mark your
calendar will be May 24th same same time
10: a.m. Pacific uh we have Sergey kaken
versus gorg Meyer a couple of really
solid players I'm really interested
interested to see how that match breaks
down so uh don't uh don't do anything
else be today before you go to chess.com
and mark down your full calendar make
sure you know when you're supposed to be
here and watch these shows uh all right
Anna the bishop pair for white some
dangerous threats of this D6 pawn and
the A7 Pawn Falls feels like this one's
headed the direction of the not looking
good for Sergey I guess he was counting
on the Move Rook E2 but you can't even
play that because of Rook A8 check and
the kick had nowhere to go absolutely um
Rook e would
have Pawn down Bishop versus knight and
is D6 pass por so this is a victory for
white and if we pause a moment to to let
Danny pretend like he's a Nakamura
psychology expert we saw the first head
lean back and sip of Red Bull of the day
that means he's feeling good
first victory for Hikaru drinking his
Red Bull Red Bull sponsors Nakamura we
love when professional players have
those kind of kinds of endorsement deals
and um I have I have uh seen pictures of
many many stacks of Red Bull cases in
his house and might you might need to
think about that it could be a little
unhealthy to drink that many energy
drinks sorry Red Bull I'm just telling
the truth here but um but it's great
that he's got a sponsor I agree with you
that we should see that more often we
should see more chess players having
support just like in other sports so
let's get chess into do it the most
popular sports like football and Tennis
we are on our way with the proess league
and sponsorship deals and Esports is the
name of it and you know we've see we see
people Gather in stadiums to watch video
games so why not chess I'll make a
prediction at some point here in the in
in the future so um all right well
hikaro is is is playing accurate
technique here the point everybody C3
not really worried about night takes and
then Che to win the the B3 Pawn because
in that line white would give check and
then immediately play D7 and black would
have no ability to stop the queen so
hikaro will take back now on on D4 I'm
not sure what he's calculating oh he's
he's got the head look oh he's got
hikaro looks over the right shoulder
that's a car number 17 he wanted to give
a check first and then he wanted to give
a check and consider D7 usually the KN
goes back when we look ahead to the
right shoulder with that look everybody
that means that Caro is actually very
confident in calculating don't mistake
it so um hikaro hikaro was was in the
driver's seat and he knew it I think he
was just confirming that this was the
kind of line he wanted and um as we said
we are about to see First Blood and
Sergey will will need to strike back
with white so if he has won the
game this was very well played by Hikaru
but we also saw that Serge can defend
very well the position was very
difficult so it's normal that after
having three inferior positions s
finally correct but he is defending very
steadily just like karakin so I don't
think that it's going to be an easy
match for Hikaru I agree I think it's
going to be this is going to be a long
fight and and it's only a one game lead
showing the scoreboard now with 40
minutes left in the F minute portion
everybody real quick want to give a
shout out to some of our guest the
movers we have record observers in the
live chess uh server right now both just
following the games manually not even uh
not even just watching this show Anna uh
but in in live chess you can play guest
the move which means you follow these
games and you can you can try to
anticipate what the players are going to
do and and it keeps track and lets you
know who would the top guess the movers
were um so there's a whole bunch of you
playing Guess the move right now nimzo
nimzo Malaysian uh super uh super tamps
uh International Master uh Michael QD D5
so a lot of lot of players in there but
the winner of the last one got 22 out of
48 moves right that's pretty good I
don't think I would get 22 out of 48
right yeah I don't think we did that
well we are playing live on the show
guess the move but we are not doing so
well Danny and I we need to improve
that's right and let me just answer also
a question on Twitter because you guys
are using the hashtag speed chess and
that's great so you should tweet us more
uh Jeff is asking if we can clarify
whether the first segment is 90 minutes
or the whole match and that's a great
question it's 90 minutes for the 5 plus
2 5 minute plus 2 second games then an
hour for 3 minute plus 2 second and then
we will in the VAR end see half an hour
of bullet chess so it's going to be a
long afternoon or morning whether you
are in the state in Europe or Asia let
us know where you are tuning in from we
are going to be here for hours don't
worry and and we mean that in the most
exciting we're going to be here for
hours way right so many people tun
awesome we would love for 24 hours I'm
just I'm just joking yeah no I was I was
going to make a comparison to you know
traditional tournaments you have uh you
have these you know very very you know
even longer games than the rapid
exciting games we're seeing here but um
you don't even get this kind of access
right one of the most amazing things
that technology has afforded Us in
addition to shrinking the world and
giving more people opportunities to play
chess but technology has given us these
sort of up close and personal views
right and we saw last year with some
some tweets going viral by our our buddy
Anton squared me and other things right
you see some really really funny moment
when the players are are laughing or or
letting or being upset and showing their
emotions um really clearly so um I think
I think it's about as easy to watch a
three-hour chess show when in this
format than anything else in in terms of
over theboard tournaments where you just
don't get to see how the players are
really feeling in a way that you would
like uh speaking of agree with you Danny
that this webcam on is my favorite
feature of the speeches championship of
course it's great that we have the top
players the world's best players
competing in the feates Championship but
an additional feature is that we can see
their facial expressions just as they
are without uh without trying to fake
that they are not happy angry nervous
whatever they feel we can see it on
their face totally and and uh speaking
of of what we what we uh showing our
emotions on our face I'm unhappy right
now because we've seen this open
multiple times and bored uh we have an
obac code Bishop position everybody and
you know perhaps aaro is comfortable
feeling like he's not going to lose
these ones but um you know I'm a little
surprised by nakamura's opening choices
black to be perfectly honest I I think
that uh these positions are are just not
going to afford black really any winning
chances if you feel like you're the
stronger player and and maybe maybe
Sergey will be the one to change because
if he tries a few times to win and and
you know is just beating his head
against the wall maybe he'll change it
up I agree with you that this seems to
be too passive for hikaru's style but
maybe this is his match strategy that
he's going for the win with the white
pieces and the draw with the black
pieces I've never seen Hikaru played
like this so I'm surprised as well but
maybe this is his new
strategy yes certainly could be possible
uh we uh remind everybody uh we have
still 35 minutes left of 5 minute after
the five minute portion is over in fact
after every portion we will play an
immediate chess 960 so if you're looking
for things to be mixed up that is
literally what CH 960 is all eight
pieces on the back rank are mixed up uh
and and it's a ton of fun so for those
of you who don't know what chess 960 is
uh make sure you stick around for the
last game of every time control before
we transition to the faster portion will
be a really fun and interesting chess
960 also called Fisher random uhoh uhoh
something happened here and you can see
I did not look for a moment I was
reading the chat oh that's Rook on A4
and here comes the second sip of
something it's only water so not Red
Bull gregorians can take uh but look at
that that's hi Caro number 12 that's a
rare H Caro where he purses the lips a
rare sighting right there everybody
you're welcome that is a that is a rare
not quite as rare as the groundhog you
know sticking out of his head out you
know before groundhog day but pretty
rare and look at that attack here comes
the head Bob that's a Nakamura and the
legendary headbob he knows he's winning
he has calculated a D4 look at that move
a brilliant move everybody the point and
I'm going to risk messing up the board
is that if Bishop takes D4 the bishop
comes to B3 and the white pieces have
strangled them elv uh with our bug here
I'm going to RIS that that fix it of
course the pawn cannot capture because
of the Rook hanging so uh surprisingly
an equal position that I ended up being
wrong about turned really exciting as
soon as white got his rook in trouble
now sergey's done that twice Anna he's
now gotten his Rook trapped on Awkward
squares in two games right exactly two
times and two times it was the Rook on
the fourth rank white Rook on the fourth
R getting trapped already for the second
time yeah unfortunately um still needed
to do a refresh after the uh the
analysis risk there we were not seeing
the live position we're working on
fixing that right now for those of you
who've been here the whole time you've
seen me multitasking pretending it like
I'm not doing it when I'm off camera but
trying to get a couple things fixed we
did some big changes today we've made
some huge improvements to bug house and
all kinds of stuff uh but something went
a little wrong here so apologies for
that we are getting it fixed um all
right well H5 that's a powerful waiting
move I guess the point Anna is that even
if the pawn takes you're still going to
get the Rook trapped on Bishop B3 at
some point right
yeah yes that is the one I see Mike
commentating on this uh Rook on A4 that
interference is a chess kit King level
59 Sergey needs to level up Sergey needs
to level up chess kid has the best
content for learning in terms of as you
solve things you actually level up and
so you're rewarded and it's uh a really
kind of a fun way to do things for kids
you know they get rewarded fireworks go
off things get a little weird over there
but it's fun for the kids so um yeah so
interference that's a tough one also
getting your pieces trapped I feel like
that was like King level 13 so um this
is this is a no jokes aside it's not
that simple I think um hearu obviously
felt confident we saw him with his
legendary headbob but but it's it was an
easy thing I think for Sergey to miss
because in in such a simply uh it's it
looks like a harmless position right
Anna it doesn't look like there's much
going on but but this Rook being trapped
on A4 just changes everything it makes
white really really under the gun as far
as now dealing with this past Pawn um
this is a tough one now for white oh
this this is a horrible position I feel
like this is even worse than the
previous one we have seen and uh I feel
sorry for Serge because this is such a
painful position you cannot move your
pieces it is still material equality but
it feels like you are already a rook
down yeah Grandmaster Max illingworth is
recommending an idea with with perhaps
Rook to G1 and G4 or maybe even G4 and
then Rook G1 his idea is to maybe the
rook and Bishop might create some
counterplay working together over here
and here okay and so Sergey is uh is
agreeing with Mr illing with it looks
like that might be the best way for
white to get counterplay but there's
risk in here no matter what I think at
certain point we see hikaro um sitting
up and Zoning in right now and I was
just going to say it's because he's
calculating whether he can play D2
everybody the reason why white couldn't
just come back with Rook D1 one is
because you'd see Bishop B3 attacking
both Rooks so so illing uh illingworth
uh gets his idea played but maybe it
wasn't the best idea now Sergey has to
sacrifice The Exchange in order to keep
the game
going yeah this is once again an
exchange down for Sergey and uh I think
it is not an exchange down that you can
hold even if he gets the D2 point it
means that you will manage to play Rook
C2 as black so I don't think that white
can survive this and I see Uncle Yermo
is here with us as well in the CH shout
out to to Alex and he says that three
draws and now it's all downhill for
Sergey draws and maybe downhill it's
possibly could be right I mean I'm not
I'm not going to I've seen him defend a
worse position Down The Exchange already
where we thought he was going to lose so
I'm not going to I'm not going to call
it dead yet for for Sergey I actually
think he's got some interesting holding
chances here hikaro has some he has some
things to figure out it's uh even though
it it looks terrible right now for white
there's not clear path in and if a lot
of Pawns come off the board it may it
easier for white to hold so I'm not
going to I'm not going to call it dead
just yet okay the Rooks come off though
that that probably helps aaro in the
initial sense but we'll see if he can
keep enough pawns on the board to have
good winning
chances yeah and once again the time
situation is not something that makes it
easier to hold this position Serge only
20 seconds on the clock and 240 for
Hikaru yep I was trying to highlight
Hikaru would play a five before he did
it but he beat me to it um one thing we
should we should note Anna is the uh the
interesting observation you made last
time that the King was in the right
color corner and the bishop was
perfectly suited to defend if this
position becomes one that moves the
other direction and white is forced to
guard the pawns over here now he does
not have the right color Bishop right so
there's that's that's one of those
things that if we're trying to learn
from top players everybody and you're
not just here for the awkward jokes from
me and and uh the uh the what you know
the chess analysis you want to learn
that you have to keep the bigger picture
in mind and not get caught up in just
the X's and O's of every move because
then the X's and O's get worse and worse
because you didn't really take the time
to establish where the game is headed so
here I think Karo knows that if this
heads in this direction Anna that he has
decent winning chances because it's the
wrong color corner for the bishop yeah I
agree that this is not the same scenario
and we will see um once again that black
can actually trade Pawns and whether
yeah look at that going going towards
the other Corner King E1 but I don't
think he can just go to the king side
now with the queen typ pawns they still
on the board yeah but it's interesting
because aaro might like to normally do
some sort of sacrifice on B2 and and get
past Pawns of his own but it's not
simple when white has the F Pawn so here
goes Sergey again I mean he has proven
if nothing else he's a super resourceful
Defender I mean he's created a scenario
you know where the bishop is actually
doing everything it needs to do guarding
the pawn weaknesses and uhoh do we have
a sacrifice okay I thought we might have
had a sacrifice in a winning King and
pawn ending but hikaro decides nay yeah
I think the white King was also fast
enough so he couldn't but it's a very
interesting uh idea that Sergey found I
didn't realize that leaving the bishop
on E5 means that you have all pawns
protected and you can simply move the
white king yeah fascinating and and
again he's he's he's very resourceful he
notice he didn't everybody which talked
about hikaro being aware that he would
win if the King was in the wrong color
corner but but gregorians was also aware
and he didn't choose a defensive plan
that was just buckled down and wait for
the hammer to be dropped um he he came
up with a creative solution so okay
hikaro is hikaro is going to do his best
to make winning chances um but how can
he win this I think this is this is
going to be a draw the only thing I can
think of is if you it's time I I'm
looking at time but go ahead yeah one
one is time and the other is if you can
sacrifice The Rook for the bishop and
the F Pawn in a way that the white king
is still too far and you get to the B2
pawn and promote your a pawn yeah he's
created a scenario now Anna where that's
not a bad idea at all but now the king
is really cut off let's say he gets the
king here and somehow finds a way to
quickly sacrifice and get both a bishop
and pawn he may win a king and pawn
ending everybody but but but Sergey has
has played fast enough that with the
increment he's now got more time than he
did 10 moves ago and so you got to have
you got to uh tip your hat again to the
very resourceful defensive
skills uh H
what oh he he he Carl blundered possible
because of the hanging Rook on E7 but
does it help yeah it certainly un misses
A3 and now it's over oh he gave a little
smile did you see that that's sad yeah
it's it's over now and now uh now white
will will actually just be lost um very
very smart play Sergey shakes his head
that was sad in fact uh hikaro ends up
winning the game because of a
resourceful trick not because he he
really grinded out so really we got to
tip our hat to Sergey again but
unfortunately it is a game not a science
and part of a game is the sporting
aspect of time pressure Anna and hikaro
is hikaro is getting his opponent under
time pressure like he does like he does
probably better than
anybody uh I see that Jeffrey Jeffrey
Kong is also here one of the
participants of the Spees championship
and he's saying the same that it was a a
tough game and yeah we feel sorry for
Ser but as you said this is sports and
Hikaru competed very well going for a
final trick and lots of more time on his
clock so kudos to Hikaru not necessarily
a back breaker obviously if you're if
you're just joining us or if you've been
here you know that you know the the
match is only a two game deficit
currently for the Challenger uh Sergey
gregorians obviously with Nakamura being
the favorite uh but so not a back
breaker but as a car starts to convert
on those games now instead of Sergey
kind of resourcefully holding you just
get the feeling that that means the
writing will be on the wall if he can't
play faster as the time controls get
faster uh it's only going to get worse
right yeah we shall see if he can manage
to create attacking chances because we
have seen Sergey being very resourceful
in terms of Defense but now that he's
down three about two points he has to he
has to cre winning chances even with the
black pieces he has to do something and
I don't want to get Uncle yero all fired
up in the chat cuz we know how he can be
but look at that Knight in front of the
Bea I know Uncle yero doesn't like once
again we've seen this Russian school boy
rule broken the reason everybody the
Jokes Aside it's a positional rule is
because normally what happens is what
you're seeing the Knight is sort of
chewing on granite on a square like that
with no real Mobility a knight behind a
pawn is a totally different scenario
where the pawn and Knight often work
together attacking the same square so
this ends up being a position where the
knights are sort of clumsy um and and
and maybe kind of get kicked around so
um you know Theory and the specific
reasons of every position can kind of
change things like that but the overall
strategical rule is you know black wants
to avoid this kind of thing that keeps
happening where now his Knights are
being pushed back and he's clearly
playing with a space disadvantage we
just saw Nakamura number 12 again if
everyone's paying attention to the purse
lips that's not I think it's the I think
it's the tartness of the Red Bull that's
making his lips purse is it I think it
is if I had to guess on the
reason we have some stats and info from
Mike again and he's saying that
gregorians played the Kings Indian
defense as black at the 2016 European
Bliss championship and beat Navara so it
seems that now that he's down two points
he's really choosing openings that
served well for him even with the black
pieces creating attacking chances so
it's great that we will see a more
aggressive Sergey going for Hikaru but
this position I'm not sure that he is
actually doing well and the mic that
Anna is referencing everybody if you're
if you're not not aware is FIA Master
Mike Klein our director of content over
on chess.com and chess kid also known as
fun Mike on also know as fun Master Mike
on chess kid but you can follow Mike uh
on on Twitter I think he's chess Mike
and of course Mike Klein writes a lot of
news reports so if you're wondering who
is this mythical Mike who's giving them
stats information it is fed Master Mike
knows fun Master Mike and papa bear yeah
well they know fun Master Mike but uh
he's uh anyway he does a lot more than
just make awesome videos for kids so
thank you Mike for continuing to help
make the show amazing all right 94 I
like that move the black pieces are
going to try to unwind and that's a
tactic everybody uh if white just
captures everything and tries to win a
pawn there's going to be a rook on the
same line as the queen uh that's going
to lead to some issues there I think for
for white so Nakamura he initially gave
the eyebrow scowl meaning I disapprove
but now he's giving the maybe I
miscalculated look and that's not exact
if you look everybody that's not exactly
the over I'm better that's the uh okay
how am I going to handle this Nakamura
look so um this is a new facee this is a
phase that we haven't seen today yet
yeah yeah and Sergey bobbing his head a
little bit look at that right we love
that we love the little confidence this
is why they need to make online I mean
uh they need to make over theboard
events more like our events Anna I would
love to see bobbing his head or Sergey
bobbing his head as he's a little bit
you know confident in the position let's
get over this classical boring way that
every tournament has to be the most
quiet and uh and uh you know Ser thing
in the world you know yeah um yeah this
is really a great feature he's got a
sack check out this could really make
chess one of the best Esports because
look at this is such an excitement to
watch these two battling it out yeah
hikaro hikaro has calculated KN D5 what
is going going on here either Sergey
missed that or hikaro felt like he was
kind of backed into a corner once that
that pony popped into D4 so um but 95
looks like a mess they they W they pay
me to talk not to actually work hard and
calculate Anna so why don't you do
that uh thank you Danny I'm just kidding
I'm just kidding no why don't why don't
you tell everybody what's going on cuz
we know I don't have the skills to no
I'm just kidding it looks like what the
heck is going on here 95 I me the point
everybody is a capture leads to a
capture back and you know temporarily
down a piece but but black has just as
many issues to deal with on the E file
uh as he did before when the queen was
under attack so I um yeah but there's
this pin on the dile and now Rook B4
attacking the C4 bishop and the
D4 xray attack is there a capture on E6
and then a take with F7 check maybe we
lose one of the Bishops but if white can
create some T now but uh yeah without
the bishop on C4 he can take back on F7
with the queen so Rook B4 I think that
is a great move and now I want to see
hikaru's face yeah Hikaru is he's leaned
in and and I think he's he's got it he
knows this is a critical moment he may
have to decide for a practical resource
such as sacking a piece and admit that
he miscalculated or he's trying to
convert on something I think one thing
that is telling Anna is take a look at
the clocks right how often do we see
Hikaru being the one down on time and
for those who are wondering oh that just
means he's thinking and thinks he's
winning normally aaro is up on time when
he thinks he's winning so um
yeah so that's an interesting
interesting observation that hikaro
feels like he's needing to justify this
position yeah I think sery is doing
great and that's what Hikaru face says
Hikaru Clark says the position is still
amess but we feel like there is nothing
that could bring back the material to
White so he's a piece down he has
sacrificed a piece with Knight D5 aiming
for this pin on eile let's calculate
this line if takes E6 I think he takes
on D4 no that would allow takes with Che
but what ises so how does C4 he wants
Rook takes C4 but Rook takes C4 okay but
then if we take F7 with check you're
just capturing back Queen I guess yeah
and now the bishop is pinned so okay um
looks like I'm still having what line is
happened is that the line that happened
in the game or I'm still having these
issues no hikaro is still thinking and
he's going really down on time but this
is a position that if he doesn't make
the best move then he might be just lost
on the spot maybe he's already lost the
the question is whether those pawns can
can do something to compensate for the
piece but I feel like he's losing more
material because of this D5 and the
Bishops on the fourth
rank yeah he's he's a little frustrated
he's leaning in and I think he's he's uh
he's thinking
about um something went wrong here I
mean he maintains a a sacrifice of the
peace CU he didn't take anything but
he's got a couple pawns for it so I
guess he's he's maybe just going to say
well we'll see if my opponent can
calculate his way out of this because
now black has to play the right
technical moves
here um so okay let's um let's see so if
black was to just move the Queen off
let's say
what happens
then so you you just want to move the
queen
anywhere yeah I mean let's okay so here
comes Rook that Rook takes D5 takes and
takes
[Music]
um yeah he wants to take both Bishops
he's giving up the Rook for the two
Bishops after Bishop takes D5 Rook takes
D4 and Bishop and then Rook takes D5 but
he's going to be pin on the E5 still so
is this working look at that move that's
a that's an awkward inner mizo there by
white and
KN attacking The Rook both Rooks but but
almost both Bishops are hanging too
right this is an absolute mess uh is
this uh sergey's best chance is to is to
continue to calculate on his opponent's
clock so that he can make moves I think
and put the pressure on Nakamura who's
now under a minute um and
uh
and now what now now white has now black
has to deal with the threat so the point
is I guess hikaro is saying that okay if
you move the Rook off the fourth rank
now I can capture and there's no Rook
takes D4 so for those who are wondering
the simple threat that's exactly it
white is trying to force the Rook away
so that he can capture on D5 without
this threat and so gregorians has to
come up with either keeping the Rook on
the fourth rank Anna maybe Rook A4 or or
or or look to capture on D4 immediately
but then Queen takes B4 and suddenly
again gregorians goes down the exchange
that's been the theme of the day has
been hikaro winning the exchange somehow
yeah he will have two minor pieces but I
don't like the fact that the C Pawn is
still on the board so that is an
annoying pass
Pawn Robert is suggesting Rook takes C4
and after Rook takes Queen H4 pinning on
the fourth rank that is a very
interesting tactical idea Rook takes
Rook takes and queen H4 classic Bobby
Hess looking for some sort of M look at
that Serge is going for it he's going
for that line oh no but not he doesn't
follow
with so this is still an issue for
hardar I that's kind of what Robert's
idea was based on too everybody is
despite the fact that
Nakamura won that Rook um white white
has some issues here I mean the bishop
is pinned and queen
wowers so hikaro is nodding his head but
I think this time more in kind of an
acknowledgement that he'll probably be
happy that he didn't lose this game
because it felt like he was under
pressure and uh and on his way there
with all the Bishops being pinned right
yeah um the ma Dizzle thank you for the
rook and no pawns but there are only
three pawns on the king side this could
be a draw if white plays well he's not
threatening Rook takes E6 at the moment
because of the back rank made with Rook
D1 but that is a threat on the long run
so next move if H3 or G3 and then Rook
takes C6 could be a threat but the
bishop is hanging what about Rook takes
C8
here Bishop yeah I was just going to say
did he just miss that Rook takes C8 yeah
I think Sergey missed it and after
captures King up
uh Bishop A3 wow wow what a resource the
only fantastic resource OMG as the kids
say
and if Rook A2 Rook takes C8 that that's
right because he guards C1 so hikaro
hikaro is is kind of kind of shaking his
head here that's a little bit of an
acknowledgement that he just wishes he
had he had won because he wishes he wins
every game but I think aaro secretly is
happy he he's he kind of he kind of
worked his way out of that one because
he was certainly Under Fire um yes I
think he was in trouble there must have
been something with so many pins on the
board and when he sacrificed the peace
it didn't looked like it was actually a
correct sacrifice to the untrained
hikaro eye the nod right there looked
like hikaro number four which is kind of
what he does when he's winning anyway uh
but that was actually a nod that that
was actually nod number seven which
means that okay I'm pretending to be
upset with myself but I'm actually
secretly happy because I defended a
worse position so there you go that's
that's that's the translation can we get
a Wikipedia page started about these
translations please maybe we should and
you should get more Hikaru faces behind
you I know that you have two in the
studio fun fact uh one of the only times
that Sergey gregorians has achieved a
victory against Nakamura has been as
white playing against taro's Berlin so
we see a we see a switch up Anna from
the from the sort of nimzo Queens
indian-ish position we've been seeing
that led to that very equal middle game
and we have our first E4 opening and uh
as as Mike Klein is now confirming the
stats that I I had already one of the
few stats I was aware of ahead of time
um is that gregorians has beaten
Nakamura in the Berlin before H so
Berlin or not Berlin but he is trying to
play for a win that is what Serge is
doing in the last few games we saw him
very very solid in the first three games
and they ended up in a draw but once he
he lost those two games in the match now
he really has to go for it no matter
what color and no matter who is the
opponent because right Karu is leading
he is up to now three no two points I
cannot I cannot add up two numbers still
up two
points I can't add up two numbers either
I'm still convinced one plus oneals
three um and uh the okay so the
transition into more of an end game has
already happened here that's kind of
what happens in the Berlin but you know
this is one that I think favors white a
little bit in the long term if if now
now blacks Rook has a few moves to
coordinate itself I think white is
supposed to play Knight E4 here um but I
guess okay Knight E4 will be met by B6
to stop Knight C5 and then you have to
deal with Bishop to D5 coming in some
positions um okay no he goes for Knight
E2 to bring the Knight to F4 and heading
to
F4 I see that there are more and more
people in the chat so let's just give a
shout out to Gar Meer as well another
participant of the speech as
Championship so we see that Jeffrey is
here uh M gar Meer is here and uh so
many other not not only titled players
because I want to give a shout out to
everybody who is here whether you are a
titled player or not it's just great
that you are here and that you share
this moment with us when Hikaru is
taking on Serge kakin in The Opening
match of the speeches Championship Serge
gorian you you you you you went to the
old you went to the other Sergey but yes
gregorians did I did I say kakin yeah
you did but it's okay I realize well
it's cuz you had it you were seeing gorg
Meyer in the chat and you were being
reminded of who he's playing of course
as we see here I'm excited for all the
players including Serge kakin that's
right that's right and that's totally
understandable so uh well black has I
guess found a way to get the Rook back
in the game but I I still like
gregorian's chances and I think it might
not be a mistake that Sergey has already
beaten Nakamura here he seems to feel
very comfortable on the white side of
the Berlin um I feel like white has the
better chances in this in this one um
what do I see when I say that I think
okay we obviously know that Berlin has
this long-term Pawn structure problem
for black and uh that means that white
has a four on three Advantage so despite
the fact that this Pawn has reached you
know H4 and maybe making this Pawn weak
it's also overextended and so if white
eventually gets the king active there
could be some targets there okay I mean
it's it's still a very very very close
to equal game assessing things very
generally
but I uh I like I like Serge approach so
far plus hikaro has been he's been all
over we've seen hikaro number 22 hikaro
number six I don't know where he's at
today in this game he's he's he's all
over the place right now not really
making it easy his
emotions also I like that Sergey is
playing faster because in the first
couple of games he was down two minutes
on the clock in every game so now at
least he keeps the pace of Hikaru that's
the first step in taking him
down I agree 100% And it's very possible
we could only be seeing one more five
minute game after this with just under
10 minutes now remaining on the total
game clock for the five minute portion
as everyone can now see from the score
of course it is a 4-2 lead for the
American uh but after this we will have
a game 960 a quick break and then then
things only get faster from there we go
right to three minutes and it gets even
more fun but there goes Knight of3 see I
like that I like that for Serge he's
coming back to hit the H4 Pawn maybe
maybe a little bit of a okay do you want
to draw because okay if he goes back to
D4 probably Nakamura repeats with the
move Knight to E6 um but Sergey I think
wants more than a draw here I okay no
maybe I'm wrong here he goes back to D4
hikaro gives the upper lip that's number
nine he gave the lip
Anna uh he goes back but I'm not sure
that he will repeat three times maybe
this is just like ask Karu are you going
for the Dr or are you aiming for more I
get the feeling with that that that that
he may be willing to repeat here and
yeah there we go that's just that just
comes from expert of just knowing hikaro
hi Caro's facial expressions nothing
with the
chessboard um but okay so now we have a
we have a four and a half two and a half
lead possibly this is the last game
depending on how quickly it's over um in
the F minute
portion yes some of you are asking very
is sery from and he is from Russia so if
you don't know that he is a Russian
Grandmaster uh he was an under 16 world
champion so he was a youth world
champion ion and I think also a lot of
credit goes to him because of qualifying
for this spe championship in the first
qualifier ahead of other strong Grand
Masters and then he kept on playing
every Tuesday and he almost qualified
again I mean he didn't he couldn't
qualify two times but he was always
finishing at the top of the standing so
I think that is a huge success uh for
Sergey knowing that players like moros
Savage Dominguez fev dubov and and drin
and so many other Grand Masters stronger
than him on the rating list played and
they couldn't qualify Sergey qualified
yeah and you're right not only did he
qualify but he was the most consistent
performer throughout the entire month of
April for those of you who may be a
little bit in the dark about what we're
talking about this uh big and awesome
bracket you see here with the world's
greatest chess players on the planet
right now uh the the 15 16 14 and 13
seeds you can see there Jeffrey Jong God
gusov gor Meer and Sergey gorian those
were all uh taken by qualifier
tournaments that we've had taking place
on chess.com for the last month and so
you know gregorians worked hard to be
here and Anna as she was pointing out it
was probably our probably the best
player on chess.com during the month of
April overall um very just very very
strong very very very good Blitz player
and so he has earned his spot to be in
this match versus Nakamura right now
okay yeah and of course once again we
are getting even more information from
Mike and he's saying that besides his
chess success he studied journalism at
the Moscow State University so he is
actually a qualified
journalist interesting and that that's
sorry mistake almost oh no that was not
that is not stud something else but he
studed something that was Mike that was
Mike testing your ability to read his
stats faster than I'm reading very fast
so
much all right well uh so far um the
this this match is is getting more and
more heading the direction of being in
control of Nakamura
um this is this is a new position we
haven't seen what can we learn from here
I we like that unlike some of the other
kings Indian attacks we've seen
everybody where it seemed like aaru was
advancing faster on the king side than
than than black was here uh Sergey has
has gotten decent counterplay he's
already used the pawn storm to open up
lines and gain
space um black seems to be in a
comfortable position here although now
now the question is how does black
continue to coordinate and get the major
pieces into the game and keep the proper
eye on the tension here you always have
to keep an eye for this Pawn may be
pushing it may be taking all these
things that are possible and and improve
your pieces at the same
time yeah that's always a question I
agree with you and uh also whether where
is the place for the queen right now
it's all right on C7 but if that was a
knight maneuver towards D5 or B5 then
once again it would be
you would need to be looking for another
Square for the queen so often times in
these positions because of the lack of
space it's not so easy to decide where
you should Place each piece of
black got
it yeah it's uh and now we see this
Knight come to B3 not quite breaking the
Russian school boy rule everybody
because he's not blocking space or
blocking pieces and in this case white
is just trying to increase the pressure
on what was kind of a critical staring
contest right now what's going to happen
with the c pwn uh black doesn't really
want to capture everybody because in a
lot of these positions you're just
giving white a very solid big Center
certainly these pawns are better than
blacks and you're opening up the C file
and likewise white doesn't really want
to capture because probably in a lot of
those positions after black captures
black black will be the first one to get
control of the defile so one of the
things you see with strong players is
they they are very smart about building
on the tension and coordinating not just
playing the obvious trade they see now
we have seen art now we're seeing maybe
our first is it is it a is it a a water
break maybe hikaro has been sucking down
a whole lot of water and red maybe a
different kind of break yeah he has
disappeared it might be for for a
different kind of break than just a
water break given how much liquid we've
seen him drinking so um well Serge
should make his move fast and take
advantage of Hikaru not being at the at
the board at the screen it's funny
because uh because Hikaru Hikaru maybe
anticipated that he could get away with
it at that time and and um
yeah jumped away of course Sergey is not
paying attention to his opponent on
camera he can the the the those
wondering about the technical setup we
have a group call going for St for a
stable connection all the players both
us and the players are on the same call
and for security that also helps with so
much at stake we always like to see
everything that's going on where we can
um and and of course it's it's bringing
you the entertaining experience you're
seeing now uh but
the the players are often not looking at
each other an so I don't think Sergey
would be aware that hikaro stepped away
he's focused on on playing I I don't
think that he's paying attention to the
group call and they are just looking at
the board you're right so he had no idea
that he could have gained some five
seconds on the clock by hikaro not being
there well okay it looks like uh this
game is going to be a few more moves in
a closed position so I'm going to bring
up the clock and show everybody that we
are really under the gun very likely now
given that I don't expect this game to
end in a couple minutes that this will
be our last five minutes minut a game so
if you're just getting here you haven't
missed too much uh actually you've
missed a lot shame on you for not being
here on time but uh but the the two
faster portions are still coming so just
as many games to come and we are about
to see a 960 battle start in uh just
about two and a half minutes so don't go
anywhere I see some new tweets so guys
keep up the tweeting as well hash speed
chess I also always love to see when you
guys post where you are watching this
match so some of you might be watching
from your laptop from your tablet uh
some of you are watching on on the TV so
uh I love those pictures please tweet
the picture where you are watching this
match that's a great idea let's give
let's give some prizes to the best
picture you know let's give some Anna
will decide on on some Diamond
memberships for anybody who is watching
it on you know maybe maybe rent out your
local movie theater I think if somebody
rents out the local movie theater that
would be maybe for the final if we get
Nakamura Carlson in the final again
let's run out a local movie theater oh
that would be
awesome well hearu uh he he was saying
something there uh perhaps to his his
fiance uh maybe there with him but uh
now he's now he's he's back to focus
also with headphones in perhaps bobbing
his head to music and not just to keep
up with the many facial expressions he's
trying to deliver me to guess
um all right but only a minute and a
half a minute and a half left means we
are very close to being sure this will
be the last fight minute game and this
has reached a very closed and locked up
position not a lot going on here just
just a bunch of minor pieces
maneuvering yeah without Rooks on the
board you can't really take advantage of
the B5 and the A5
so it is still more pleasant that you
have more space as white but I don't see
a way to make a big Improvement maybe if
you could get the Knight to B5 but even
then what's next he might continue that
plan not right away everybody as there
would be a threat on Queen takes E1 but
I think aaro is going to try to bring
one of these Knights into the B5 Square
uh Sergey doing a very good job of
ganging up on his only real potential
Target when you look at a pawn structure
like this the base Pawn is the pawn kind
of at the core of a of of a big Pawn
Center everybody or a pawn chain for
example Black's base Pawn is here on E7
and so you know this Pawn is a target
for black and if you can gang up on it
you're sure that there's no other pawns
defending it which means pieces are
stuck to doing the job so little bit of
advice there as you're looking at some
of these positions that are closed and
maybe you don't always have a plan uh
one way to find a plan is to look for
you know the pawn with no protection
from other pawns see if you can
coordinate your pieces to gang up on
that
weakness yeah look at that ganging up
against the C4 Pawn because next move
could have be Knight E5 but Hikaru
prevented it by pushing
F4 so you are letting them know that
this is the last game I
believe D5 plus two time
control and right after that we will see
a chess 960 I'm curious about that
because uh I'm not very good at playing
chess 960 but I love I love that type of
Chess as well so I want I want toar I'm
not very good at chess but I love
playing chess so I mean I said I'm not
very good at chess and I love playing
chess so I'm all about that you know you
got you got to play that as well but now
talking about Chess 960 it also applies
also so a ton of fun I agree hikaro
instantly plays E5 there wow really
confident about this plan and he's going
to lose the bishop pair but but he takes
on D6 of course black cannot capture on
E3 everybody as white would have taken
on E7 and gotten a queen but um so now
we have two base pawns Under Fire
potentially in right you have a base
Pawn for black on D6 which white would
love to gang up on somehow and you have
a base Pawn for white shaking his head
because the black king is coming so the
D6 Pawn will be well protect protected
and the C4 Pawn is not so easy to
protect is are there tactics Knight
takes C5 I don't know if saw this coming
because A6 is Hing
again again Sergey might have blundered
because a bishop takes
C4 well remember you you can't always
trust nakamura's head shakes sometimes
he shakes his head right as as he's I I
did I missed it I can't give my expert
opinion of of what Nakamura headshake
that was number four number seven number
11 but maybe he was shaking his head
because it was a beautiful tactical
motive but in the end he didn't win
material with it so that was this
hanging Pawn on C4 luckily for
black yeah so neither side really able
to get anything concrete out of the
other side's Pawn weaknesses but now if
we're evaluating we kind of like Black's
chances because if we're looking at King
activity Black's King is serving a true
purpose guarding the pawn whereas
White's King is stuck over here which
means if black could I mean I'm I'm just
going to throw out after Knight F3 is
there a move like Knight to C3 and am I
not just going and gobbling up this D5
Pawn okay hikaro plays Knight E6 rather
than Knight F3 but I'm still curious why
okay yeah so here comes Knight E3 I I
feel like if anybody can win this end
game it's going to be going to be Sergey
now here comes the D5 Pawn falling and
oh wait hikaro has tricks Knight to f8
check followed by for the6 yeah so I
think aaro might be saving the day with
this uh little back and forth with the
Knight guarding the D5
Pawn yeah looks like we're going to get
another draw uh I can tell can tell by
that offer the draw let's see has been
just like that the the 5-2 portion will
come to an end and we have our first 960
game I am excited let's give uh quick
shout out for station identification
here again if you're just getting here
this is the speed Chess Championship
2017 uh going to be the biggest event
happening in the online chess world for
the next 6 months or so matches all the
time check the full schedule at
chess.com TV uh Magnus Carlson car
Nakamura I don't even really need to
name anybody else because you get it um
and uh everybody everybody who who
matters in the Chess World the top
players and the chess 960 has started
you need to let me know if the pieces
are just uh randomly sorted out or how
is the rule about this in these cases
the pieces are just Rand ly sorted the
players are not told the positions ahead
of time every chess 960 position has a
specific ID uh I know there's a lot of
them but 960 possibilities but they all
have a a different ID and so the fen
string is actually what it's called for
those who don't speak chess Tech U but
the the specific F of the position is
not told to the players they are not
aware of the position they're going to
get and they don't even know what color
they're going to get because it's really
random it depends on what their last
color was at the end of the previous
time control so here you see Anna
Nakamura has the black pieces because
his last game was with white um all
right so this is crazy fun everybody if
you haven't played chess 960 ever go to
chess.com and play it it's it's fun and
free and it basically is a lot of people
considered it for a while the future of
Chess because it it eliminates so much
preparation um it it's it's a very very
difficult thing to uh to you can make
mistakes very early uh you'll notice
that Sergey uh gregorians took a few
seconds and I'm sure you were noticing
he almost took 30 seconds before making
his first move cuz he wanted to decide
on a plan cuz it's never it's not a
position he's prepared to play yeah
right yeah this this is really exciting
about Chess 960 and they can Casto as
well K so you can CLE Queen side in this
position or can you also CLE King side
with the Rook on E1 I don't that's right
you well no you cannot you can Castle
King side with Rook on E1 but obviously
not with these pieces here um if in
another case if for instance The Rook
was on G8 or only if the Rook is in the
corner like in traditional chess you can
Castle to either side in any ch60 game
as long as you follow the traditional
rules of the king and Brook heav so
there actually are no traditional cing
there's no exception at cing in chest
960 no no matter how awkward it looks I
mean if you have a king on A1 and and a
couple Rooks over there on the king side
you can steal Castle King side as long
as none of the pieces squares are
blocked so in this case if white picked
up this King and moved it to A1 you
would see The Rook go to D1 and the
white king go to C1 it would become an
immediate queenside Castle so at some
point nakam or or Serge or Nakamura
Nakamura can also get castled here
simply by dragging his King on top of
the A8 Rook um but neither side wants to
get castled yet look at Sergey putting
his Queen on the Square and and keeping
an eye on A7 I believe in case black
castles long he has a quick back door
with the queen slipping into A7 that
would be
sweet yeah he he is certainly scaring
Karu keeping his King in the middle of
the board right and it's I think the
funny thing about CH 960 is that after
some 20 moves the position will look
totally normal because they end up
playing the the usual moves so the
pieces go to the best squares and uh
even though they did not start in the
normal way now look at this position
isn't it normal chess yeah very normal
right it would be hard to guess the
opening we'll say that but yes it is
very it is very traditional looking
because um it's almost like a a like an
opposite French right instead of a pawn
structure here structure here you've got
black with the dark squares white with
the light squares um yeah I think
White's a little better here I think
nakamura's position is a little worse uh
on the note of what positions we choose
as we just saw both players Castle along
so that's cool for those who don't know
how that works but uh the other the only
real effort we put into the positions an
ahead of time besides keeping it secret
from the players um is we try to get
positions where the initial computer
evaluation is as close to equal as
possible one of the dangers of Chess 960
that people don't understand is that
some of the positions that are chess 960
are because the pieces are so awkward
sometimes white actually has a very big
Advantage because the initiative in a
position that's not classical chess is
so much more dangerous right and so we
we try to do our best um I say we
usually uh Peete our our senior editor
and events manager he he takes that very
seriously and tries to pick positions
that are very very dynamically equal so
everyone can trust that that's something
we
do all right look at that Knight coming
to B4 there could some Danger on the
Queen's side yeah this isn't a Russian
school boy mistake anymore everybody
this is Sergey about to get his attack
on here comes Knight A5 and you're going
to see a couple of knights aiming in on
these pawns and look at hik Caro's Queen
and Knight this is not IDE I expect
we'll see a move like Bishop C8 from
Nakamura and then maybe even a chance to
either get the queen over or get the
Knight over ah I'm wrong look at his
plan I bet he's going for the Mel to put
a knight on C8 and that's how maybe this
is his plan is to to maneuver a knight
to defend well is that good enough in
order to defend the B7 Pawn because I
would be afraid of the queen coming to
F1 and then Knight takes
B7 yeah well I think he'll probably
leave this B he always has probably so
no but you're right I mean if Bishop
maybe there's other ways to I think
Serge is better here don't I mean even
with the plan that we're happy I love
his position look at the pressure on the
queen side I agree I think I think that
this is a a very good chance for Sergey
to strike where despite being down two
games at the end of five a five minute
he he could be only down one game which
I think if you asked him prematch Anna
if he would take that only being down
one game headed into a three minute I
think he would say yes certainly I
wanted to say that now Queen F1 and I'm
so scared as black of Bishop takes A6
agreed Town population us here it comes
you have to go Bishop C8 in order to
prevent B6 what what Knight takes A6
Knight takes C7 this is about to get
nasty look at this something weird is
going to I think this is bad hikaro is
one of the things he does so well and he
may still lose this game but I think he
recognizes he was in trouble and so
notice how quickly he's been playing his
best chance from a practical perspective
is probably to just put the pressure on
on Sergey and see if he doesn't convert
then maybe he won't have the time later
on so um and he didn't go for Knight
takes he goes Knight C6 and now after A5
the pawns are not hanging anymore so
yeah this might be hikaru's secret that
even in a bad position he goes he plays
very quick and confident so you question
yourself whether your sacrifice is good
enough yep I agree and now and serge is
only getting down further on time so he
either I mean what's going on here he's
going to he didn't go for the exchange
he plays Bishop C2 first ah there was a
threat of Queen A6 mate duh okay yes um
yeah now maybe he takes takes before
brings the Knight back to maybe E6 and
tries to get the light score Bishop off
the board that would be my idea if I was
Sergey I would I would look to do a
little chop chop and put the pony here
with a threat because if I can get the
light score Bishop off the board I feel
like that gives me better long-term
chances of attacking black so that's my
I accept your idea I think that that
would be really great to get rid of that
Bishop on C8 we see Ser that as well
okay hi Caro recognizes that
inside I'm just going to sack The
Exchange right
away absolutely and we are getting some
more information now from Pete that
according to stockfish Grandmaster
stockfish white is a head plus
three according to Grandmaster stockfish
white is a head plus three Pete Pete
loves giving us information with from
stockfish it's it's it's uh thank you
Pete it's great so
uh it h yeah okay he carries back I was
very dead once again we lost
him I'm just responding to some team
messages here making sure everything is
set so this is the first game where the
exchange up is not for Hikaru we have
seen Sergey losing his Rook two times
already now it is his time to win with
the Rook against the minor piece but the
position is so far really close he has
to open up the position for the
and again look at time I mean this is
the first time we've seen more minute
time
Advantage game right hikaro knows that
if you know obviously if his opponent
wins this is much closer M two- game
deficit is a big big difference and if
hikaro somehow swindled to win it would
be huge right so so Nakamura would love
to hold this position and not let
gregorians bring it back to a one game
lead look at this very nice plan though
bringing the knight from D3 eventually
going to come all the way to D5
everybody that is gregorian's plan um
whoa Knight F5 with a discovered check
oh that is some sassy business oh and
hiar wins on time Gregorian the
Gregorian loses on that is why he's
hikaro Nakamura and for those who
couldn't see it cuz I wanted the chess
960 ban up the moment he won hikaro
knows because he's been here before that
he has a few minute break and he takes
it we will let Sergey know that we have
exactly a 3-minute break as of the end
of that game um letting him know that he
has a quick break before we move to the
faster time controls so that he can uh
perhaps take a breath and and step up
that's that's got to be disappointing to
have such a huge Advantage this this
must have been so painful even even
after this night F5 move it's not the
end of the world you don't have to take
it in the first place the the the key
everybody is is aaru okay first of all
he doesn't want to sit tight and allow
Sergey to continue a plan of dominating
D5 so a very resourceful idea by hikaro
to sort of meet him in the middle say if
you're going to dominate D5 I'll
dominate D4 and it's based on a trick
that Sergey was probably calculating
when he lost on time after captures
check and the King moves white gets uh
the queen and Rook forked after Pawn to
E3 so super resourceful uh defensive
play by Nakamura and that Anna if we're
going back to the scoreboard here I mean
that's a that's a GameChanger right now
we're looking at a scenario where a
three game lead what going to be a one-
game lead for the American is now a
three-game lead a huge two-point
swing yeah it could have been just one
Serge was an exchange up and he was
playing so well I'm sure that he had
something even more than this winning
the exchange with Knight C6 because it
felt like that with the King on A1 and
those sacrifices on A6 white was about
to give
M yeah just just fascinating white was
white was really in control of this game
super super great defensive resources
there and uh unfortunate for the
Challenger in this in this scenario not
the favorite that he was unable to get
this chess 960 game um after after after
what was looked to be almost an amazing
attack developing so but okay I mean
we're here to see exciting chess and
even though we started with three draws
we are we are getting our money's worth
Anna um and we are we are certainly
getting our money's worth and shout out
to Chris dictator Cilla Christian is
here in the chat as well uh he has done
some amazing work in the St Louis team
at the US Chess Championship and now
he's here in the chat uh also as always
shout out to everybody every chess.com
member also whether you're a diamond
member Gold Member what other
memberships are there by the way Danny
you need to inform me uh Diamond members
there's Diamond memberships Platinum
memberships and gold memberships I'm not
even sure uh are you asking because
you're ready to give away some
memberships I'm hoping too go for it go
for it give away yeah give away a
one-month Diamond membership right
now right now I wanted to give it to
somebody from the picture contest but I
don't want to give it yet let's just
announce once again that we are
expecting on Twitter with the hashtag
speed chess pictures of where you are
watching this match from whether it's
your laptop your computer your TV take a
picture of that and post it on Twitter
with the hasht speed chess right now
during the match and can I have three
winners Danny please go for it you can
have three winners let's three winners
for MERS many I'm the oper of diamond
memberships today everybody gets one um
all right so the uh the match is going
to continue now everybody if you're just
joining us let's do the mat we're about
to start but this is the first of the
the first round where we're going to
have so many awesome awesome matches uh
we are looking at Nakamura versus
gregorians and um this is so far been
been a very exciting match of pregame
lead currently for the Americans some of
the games have been uh super exciting
and close our next match make sure
you're already marking your calendar for
it you're like what in the world is this
this is awesome it's May 24th and uh
without any further Ado the three-minute
portion is underway so Ann and I will
we'll get back to to um well we'll we'll
get back to to just that the games are
underway and so let's uh there three
minutes plus 2 second portion for 1 hour
the players will be playing Blitz Games
with this time control three plus two so
3 minute and 2
seconds somehow we lost hikaro Nakamura
um hopefully he can he can call back uh
there he goes here hiar is back and it's
also his move and uh and I'm not sure
he's aware of it we should probably let
him
know oh he has made his move he is aware
of it okay cool so hi Caro stepped away
he's back and uh all is well we are
35 seconds into the 3-minute portion now
and uh this will be 1 hour of 32
Blitz the uh the funny thing about this
is so many of the players who play
regularly on our site Anna they don't
normally play games with increment a lot
of the favorite for for players is just
sudden death right you want to flag
somebody and beat them on time so but
it's one of the things we like about the
speeds Championship because it helps us
to make the X's and O's on the board
matter just as much as the fast time
control because we've seen these players
win games when they're literally living
on the two seconds they get added for
every move so um this I think that helps
the reason I bring that up talking about
the time controls is because I do think
it help sometimes the the let's say the
the slower player or the lower rated
player Nakamura known as being so fast
right I think that even though 3-2 is
faster and we've seen Sergey struggle to
with taking more time I think it does
keep the match you know a more of a
better chance that there could be some
sort of comeback or or an upset because
those extra few seconds really helps I
think sometimes the low r player to be
able to think and stay on the board with
a super grandm like
Nakamura yeah also this was a St control
of the qualifying tournaments where
Sergey managed to take the first place
so I believe that he's feeling confident
with this time control and he has a good
chance to at least win a game or two
because he hasn't won a game yet let's
just see that the score is 63 but with
draw so he hasn't won a game yet and I
think he should he's capable of winning
yeah I I agree I think uh well we we
just saw a game where we thought he was
going to win he was on Pace to do so in
that chess 960 battle that if you're
just joining us you missed but uh stick
around and uh thanks to everybody who's
continuing to follow And subscribe to
our channel uh mucho gracius and uh
let's
uh that wasn't too bad what that wasn't
too bad the pronunciation was pretty
good oh yeah I know I know you're fluent
in Spanish so I uh I speak a little bit
but I'm not even going to say that
because I'm just going to be embarrassed
by you but the pronunciation wasn't bad
right I mean I do specialize in accents
for a living um which you should do that
more often I H I have listened to some
of your streams yeah with the certain
accents that you are a master of today
today I think we're just usually the
accents come out as the fireworks happen
because it's something I can't control
half the time I'm blacked out um but the
U okay so the ex's and O's of this one I
really like the way these Kings Indian
attacks are going for the American I
feel like Sergey needs to figure out how
he wants to deal I mean hikaro is
playing just like a very straight
forward plan here he he fian Kett the
bishop on the king side he's going to
strike with E4 and uh then he's going to
do everything he can to REM maneuver the
pieces and just launch an attack and I
feel like Sergey has tried multiple
different defenses against it so far
right um he did he did and he keeps on
trying uh once again he's getting low on
time
yeah and and I I'm expecting if you give
white some moves here you would you
would see things you know even Ultra
aggressive like G4 coming but I was
going to say do we have to prot protect
Knight D4 first with Queen F2 but Sergey
Sergey decides to hop now into that
square this seems like the right idea
actually I like I like Black's approach
now I like it as well let's hope that
the queen doesn't get trapped because we
have seen his his Rooks being trapped on
the fourth rank now let's not do it with
the queen he's gotten some of his major
pieces in trouble if you're just joining
us there were some really exciting games
where Rooks were trapped on the fourth
rank go figure uh so we're hoping for uh
Mr gregorians that doesn't happen to the
queen here okay so who who's better here
really okay so we like Black's activity
I mean it's it's a powerful Queen and
and a decent Knight but longterm white
has the bishop pair which is important
everybody again we we've said that most
positions become more and more open they
don't become more and more closed so the
bishop pair tends to be an advantage um
as the diagonals free up uh but but Ser
is also in the default I feel like this
is a decent position for black what do
you think uh I think the same but I'm
once again I'm I'm feeling a bit of of a
danger for this queen4 I know that it's
not getting trapped right now but after
Queen C3 next move I can go Bishop G2
and you have to go to G6 or F5 and it's
not it doesn't feel good I I agree with
you actually the moment I said that
Queen to C3 was a really good move it it
it okay so the obvious threat everybody
is Nakamura would like to just go win a
piece here uh but if the Knight moved
there would have been the moves Anna was
worried about either Bishop G2 Bishop D3
some really crazy stuff with this queen
and now there's um what's going on with
Rook to D2 here
what Rook to
D2 what is going on hikaro is also this
is this is one of those super F oh but
he he he he reverted back reverted back
to aaro number number eight The
Confident eyebrow raise head Bob he
knows he's better he's going for it
what's he going to do okay no but hikaro
I think was really focused there I mean
he's calculating moves like Rook D2
what's happening here that's a skewer if
the queen moves we we can't win a piece
apparently gregorians has calculated
well enough to get Point does he want to
go queen queen F3 to pin Queen E4 back
but now no I think he has to go back to
to E4 back he has to keep other squares
open for the queen so he goes back but
now is there takes and then maybe The
Rook just comes to D1 and Carl yeah I
was going to say he just settles on
having an edge as they head to an end
game I I think this transition has
really hurt Gregorian and and the time
also says that exactly even if he didn't
lose material this was not the way to
play yeah something something bad
happened there in you're uh your worries
were correct no the queen didn't get
trapped but it was because of the
potential threats on the awkward first
first lady that she that that black had
to Black had to play those weird moves
right and still with a bishop E4 move
and then pushing the F Pawn I mean the
queen is almost
trapped well he didn't have time for it
because the Rook was hanging and maybe
it would have been too much material but
still I think he'll play G4 now and he's
still going to go for Bishop E4 I'm
anticipating why not I mean okay unless
there's yeah I was going to say why not
just G4 quickly and now here comes
Bishop E4 and double on the dile and
this just super tough for
gorian yeah I think he he is lost
positionally because of the D5 because
of the bad Queen and because of having
no
counterplay yeah Queen to A7 that's a
strong move as well uh overloading the
defender sometimes those moves are easy
to miss computers never miss them
because they don't think in human ways
like we do where someone gets
emotionally attached to the defile but
it's a nice move for hi Caro just to
recognize there are other problems with
Black's position and mainly that he just
can't defend these queenside pawns um
this is this is just going to be lost in
a sad a
sad a sad first loss for gregorians in
the 3-2 time control look at that very
nice technique says deny the queen
counterplay before I go and get that
pawn rather than takes and allow some
sort of check Everybody by the queen um
so he carries up four points and I think
this is the moment I'm I've been hinted
by Mike but I also wanted to ask you did
Sergey choose Hikaru as an opponent or
this was his bad luck it was his bad
luck Sergey did not choose hikaro as his
opponent in fact uh that's a good good
reminder people are wondering what was
the format how did we decide who would
play who here well we had four players
qualify during the month of April as
we've said a few times for this awesome
speeds Championship $50,000 in prize
fund going to be epic make sure you pay
attention but the four players who
qualified whoever was the highest rated
on chess.com in terms of their BL Blitz
rating got to choose their opponent uh
the ratings in the end uh were gorg
Meyer was the top seed and he chose
Sergey karakin so that kind of set the
rest in order players were not always
getting their Top Choice um and so
without getting into who gregorian's Top
Choice was I know that it was not
Nakamura so kind of a tough draw for
Sergey um Nakamura was along with nobody
had Nakamura and Carlson as their top
pick I'll say that what do surprise not
a surprise right people were people were
looking forward or hoping they could
they could be higher rate enough to
choose either Maxim or Sergey kak and of
course I wouldn't want to play either
one of those guys anyway but um but I
think that people definitely still see
Nakamura and Carlson as the two most
feared men in the uh in the system and
so so not nobody chose to play Nakamura
or Carlson in the first
round yes see if they want to move on to
the next round it's a smart choice not
to pick them but uh you can never know
maybe can he can he do something with
four points down can Sergey produce a
miracle and start winning games well
he's back to the Berlin I feel like this
was one of his better games so far uh
you know not just because of our
preconceived knowledge that it's one of
the only times he's beaten Nakamura in
over theboard game was on the white side
of a Berlin
um so he's he's in a Berlin now what
what's going on here
everybody we've highlighted it before
right white has a positional Edge four
on three that's healthy versus black
double pawns but but um there it's it's
a difficult position for white to win in
a lot of cases that's why you've seen it
be so popular at the high levels and uh
currently probably Black's biggest
problems he's got to figure out how he
wants to coordinate the center here get
the king out of the middle of the board
and and get the Rooks connected and
operating on the
defile um I'm surprised that he's
thinking so long about where to retreat
The Rook there are not so many available
squares yeah me too I think that it's
usually a practical mistake in those
cases just because you know you're going
to need your time later on uh he goes to
D2 maybe he was wondering if keeping the
Rook on the third rank was better so he
did that but okay the point Knight D4
was a beautiful move now Knight takes F3
was an intermediate move destroying the
white pone structure yep Knight D4
everybody was a deflector or removal of
the defender if the Knight had taken
here black would have won the bishop
with Tempo so Knight D4 was sort of
overwhelming this Knight and his duties
um and uh so that's that's why that
tactic worked for black to give you the
replay who's going to win the king andon
ending hikaro feels like he is with that
uh with that eyebrow look look at that
here he's confident hikaro when he's
calculating rapid fire it's almost like
rapid eye movement his eyes look up
because he's calculating so fast in his
head his eyes can't keep up with his
stop process I'm not even kidding
actually I think that's why he does it
also just a habit he got into so so yeah
I I think and now this F5 move might
have surprised him slightly but he
doesn't care yeah well the key is that
Serge is going to sacrifice that F5 Pawn
everybody he's going to play F4 I think
and just give up the pawn um so to
prevent that the black King enters his
position yeah yeah I think that's the
certainly the idea is is I don't think
to capture I I oh whoa he does it but
that's going to allow Hikaru what
happens here King E6 F4 King F5 and
Nakamura just wins the pawn I don't
understand why he did
that he might have miscalculated he's
one move
short I don't understand oh wait a
second no you can't take the P forgot
that you cannot take the F paom because
the e p would promote it's our first
massive
blunder H4 prevents G5 that's right it's
our first Mutual blindness Anna we
totally we have those a lot Basics it's
a basic stuff in ponent games and I have
videos on ponent games I don't even you
know know but we we do that a lot so our
first Mutual blindness of the day
whoever had the over under that it would
happen at about an hour and a half in
there you go they won they wanted we
make well back to the coffee house Anna
yeah humans
hasht but uh but okay so that means is
this is this winning for gregorians
because the point everybody is if the if
the king side sorry if the queen side
gets locked up here's how white wins let
me just give you a little quick taste of
what's coming let's say something like
this happens and the queenside is locked
up the threat is that white will white
will sack the F pawn moves like F5 check
and then King F4 will be winning for
white because black is in zwang he has
to move the king away and he's going to
lose I think aaru is sort of recognizing
that in fact before we could even do it
he resigns because that was exactly what
was
happening um exactly yeah because of the
TK that you
mentioned so wow we uh I I guess Karo
went so confidently into that King and
pawn ending with trading the Brooks that
yeah I don't and his King being more
active but you know in the end what what
told the Tale in the end I mean the
typical Berlin thing that should tell
the tail White had four pawns versus
three pawns and and white was just
positioning better so kind of a big
blunder by Nakamura to just trading that
King upon ending h exactly and we were
so confused by his confidence yeah
totally blinded by his confidence yeah
uh but it's a good lesson for everybody
there I mean regardless of the king
activity the positional Edge B basically
when you're up a pawn essentially white
is up a pawn in those end games because
Black's doubl pawns on the queen side
that was so that was instructive
hopefully everyone saw that idea of the
zwang thing um that uh could be
beneficial for their chess as well as
watching Anna's King and pawn ending
videos Anna little shout out for you I
hope that now they don't think that I'm
totally not qualified to teach it I'm
not qualified
to is
winning I normally know it right now uh
all right well okay we have another
Kings Indian attack hikaro not happy
with doing the water swish the water
swish again I think the tartness to the
Red Bull is getting to his taste buds
um so uh so we have a strike back by the
way we're under downplaying the moment
here I mean what did we just have we had
our first win for the Challenger you and
just like that ex yeah we should we
should uh congratulate Serge for his
first win because the first is always
the most difficult right so he wins and
he already had some chances earlier so
maybe that gives him some confidence
certainly that two game swing is about
as big as any I the four game deficits
have been overcome as the stat Master
Mike Klein will confirm a five-game
deficit has never been overcome in one
so that match keeps it within our our
statistical we've been doing these
things for years here on chess.com um
and uh that keeps it within Striking
Distance based on what we have known and
seen in these things that it's now it's
still only a three-game
lead
trying to keep an eye on the chat as
well and also guys don't forget that I'm
giving away three Diamond memberships
for the picture contest that is all
about taking a snap a picture of where
you are watching this match from on your
laptop on your mobile on your television
wherever you're watching from please
tweet it with the hashtag speed chess
the who what have been the best pictures
so far you said you've seen some flat
screen TV some Apple TV there nice ones
there I I won't say who is leading so
far because we have three prices but
there are some nice pictures and of
course in general we want to see where
you are watching us uh where you are
watching the match from I see some of
you are at work and you manag to watch
it on another Tab while you are working
when the boss is not watching you can
see the match if you get your boss to
watch it with you and take like a selfie
of both you that's extra oh that would
be a total winner for sure clear first
um all right so let's see we're we're in
another Kings Indian this one different
than the kingside expansions we've seen
from the American and an attack and
that's partly by the way everybody
because black also played a Kings Indian
setup one of the things that's so um
useful about this type of setup is that
it's it's generally very hard for
someone to launch this kind of Pawn
storm because even if they get there
they're sort of you know they're sort of
chewing on wood there's not a lot to do
there it's it's difficult to to use a
pawn storm to break down that kind of
setup and so um that that's why Nakamura
sort of changes plans no longer
attacking on the king side here we see a
battle over the C file commencing ooh
and tactics B5 is a sacrifice of the
pawn and we may have another exchange
exchange uh exchange deficit for
gregorians or or however you want to
look at it something Dynamic happening
there okay he plays A5 to prevent it but
now that means after A4 he has to deal
with this passive Pony the Knight is not
happy over there and this B6 Pawn that's
a horrible pie look at that Knight takes
A5 Shenanigans two pass pawns are better
than one uh that's a sacrifice is it
worth the piece in this
position I think I don't know he's
basing it on that first of all he has
Pro he has protected pass pawns and this
A7 Knight is a horrible piece so that is
the main reason why these two pawns
could be better than the Knight on A7 I
I was thinking The Rook might come to C7
hi Caro puts the bishop there and I'm
I'm anticipating he'll either rush or
just what's he he just goes gobbles E5
that's three pawns for the piece now and
maybe a fourth one to go with it so
Sergey maybe not so thrilled about yeah
now that's a that's too many pawns okay
and and so much so that he decides he's
just got to give it back but now he's
just really unhappy I mean he's still
down two pawns and not not even two Pawn
down yeah
yeah well that's that's a frustrating
one there
um this is unfortunately once again a
very a very bad situation for Serge I
don't think that he can he can by any
Miracle save it so two pawns up for
Hikaru and he's also up on time with two
minutes so it wouldn't mean a major
blunder that Hikaru needs to commit in
order to not win this game
yeah that's just it's just too much and
I think that
um I guess I guess if we're evaluating
where it went wrong there I mean the the
combination that started with B5 was
really pretty brilliant by Nakamura it
starts with this threat of winning the
exchange but the forcing of these pawns
to be targets I mean hikaro recognized
that there was there was opportunities
there and he got grabbed it back to a
four-game lead thanks to everybody who
continues to play Guess the move we have
Jay Jay Cal's chess we have have um woly
Watts Eugene able why do I even try to
pronounce usernames um anyway thanks to
everybody playing Guess the move in the
live server and um hopefully hopefully
you enjoy that trying to guess and play
like a top GM okay yeah and uh I will
shout out to all all the new tweets I
see W is preparing for his exam while
watching the match so thank you for
tuning in even in such tough times
Benjamin is watching on multiple screens
so he can follow the chat and uh the
game in a separate board as well it's
great that I see another one that's also
one Mo uh he's watching from his mobile
and he's working on his laptop at the
same time that's Moes thank you guys for
tweeting and keep those tweets coming
ashps so we have a Rosal limo Sicilian
everybody that's what this is here an
anti Sicilian or just not an open
Sicilian um white white is is is not
playing a more traditional approach
there and in these cases you see these
sort of Rook e one and H3 kind of
flexible moves often these moves are
designed that this bishop will not give
itself up for for double pawns but kind
of find a new home on F1 although now
after D6 sometimes there are ideas where
white decides to go for in fact yeah he
plays D3 I wondered if he should have
taken first Sometimes they take and then
play B3 as well but here he plays D3 I
think partly CU Nakamura employed kind
of a weird approach with the pony on H6
this is a
this is no longer that symmetrical nimzo
Queens Indian thing we were seeing to
start the match right Anna this is a
mess of a
position okay so now he takes it yeah as
soon as he played D3 we knew that plan
was changing and I like white a lot here
I like this plan with
E5 yeah this is this is a really nice
Rosal Lio for white so you you give up
the bishop in order to double black
pawns and uh try to take advantage of
the knights because this position is
pretty much closed
agree totally E5 push is so typical
sorry I just wanted to add that that
this E5 move is very typical because
black can never take there you don't
want to leave the C pawns
isolated no great point I'm glad you
added that this is the line I was
talking about that taking E5 is really
just not even an option for black
because those pawns would be so weak so
um so I agree and I and I also agree
that white is better here
um so interesting interesting stuff I I
like that Serge is not going down with
we've seen players in these matches Anna
over the years right we've seen players
who who fall in a deficit but they
really have trouble kind of adjusting
mid-match they they they don't go away
from openings that aren't working they
kind of just keep banging their head
against the wall when when for us as you
know removed emotionally the writing is
on the wall that it's not going to work
but Sergey is not doing that Anna he's
really mixing it up and trying to find
places maybe he can probe nakamura's
Blitz repertoire for a weakness right h
maybe but he had two days in order to
prepare for this match that was another
disadvantage of getting Hikaru right the
ratings that counted were from the 1 of
May so two days to prepare for uh the
best bullet player in the world one of
the most feared Blitz
players so yeah great great new for S I
guess I feel like Sergey missed his
chance I was as you were saying that
line I was highlighting for the fans
that I thought Bishop D2 was a way to
just outright win the C5 Pawn the queen
can't continue to guard the pawn and if
if Queen B5 now c4 is super strong but
Sergey Sergey played I believe a big
mistake he played C4 first and here
comes Knight E6 and now the pawn is
guarded so I I think Sergey missed I
mean I I still like white I think
positionally we agree but I feel like
Sergey might have just miscalculated
that yeah I think you are right that he
could have he could have played it
immediately C4 is a very typical move in
the r Lio so he went for the traditional
way of attacking this C5 Pawn but he
could have acted it earlier we're now
seeing H Caro shagrin head shake number
nine that is an authentic I am not happy
with my position that's not a I'm
winning or I'm drawing and I knew I was
wor that is an authentic yeah I think
Karo is not happy with this one um he'll
be lucky to draw now he's just going to
lose that C5 pawn and still be in
trouble to go with it so um so we could
again see the strike which again
statistics would tell us we need to see
a strike if if you're in sergey's
position right you got to get a win um
in order to to to keep this thing
close he's going to get this I mean he's
a pawn up but it's not only about the
pawn but this beautiful Knight outpost
on C5 this bishop on D6 in comparison
with the C8 Bishop that is such a bad
piece yeah I think the score is not
updated I think the score is actually 8
to4 in favor of Nakamura um saying that
out loud so my team hears me I think
that think that we're missing an update
on the uh on the scoreboard there guys
um but uh so because as I was saying
statistically I believe that we need uh
if you're a Sergey fan he's got to win
this game in order to keep it kind of
within within our historical Striking
Distance unless we see our first ever
five-game deficit overcome but um but
okay Sergey is really grinding this one
and this is about as a a beautiful win
in the white side of the Rosal Lio as
you can see I think aaro is just
straight up front frustrated with his
position right now yeah this is such a
pain to pay to play this position only a
p down but Black's position is crippled
you cannot do
anything word homie word and uh yeah
here comes the SE file ouch
toown
owie yeah I'm not even sure that this
was the most accurate because I was
happy not giving coun not not giving any
play to that light squar Bishop of black
I AG agree with you in fact if we just
go back to this position I mean how
beautiful was this Knight compared that
if you had a student here you would be
yelling at them right like don't take I
mean even if it's accurate and Sergey
goes on to win which I think he's still
winning I I agree with you that was a
that was a strange decision to give up a
dominant night for a big Pawn on D7 an
ugly Bishop okay but ooh resourceful
tricks here tricks are for kids he
wanted to get a Perpetual check
everybody so he sacrificed that Rook for
a chance but but Gregorian says no thank
you now Nakamura must save The Rook
Gregorian is still better but you're
right this is this is heading a
direction where you just you feel like
something slipped there in his grip
right yeah uh I think he was completely
winning with a pawn up and that
domination before exchanging his Knight
for the light Square Bishop of black and
he still is but you know even there that
was a move that I also didn't like play
Rook F3 first and threat Rook H3 while
the queen was on the he gave this sort
of instinctive check and now Rook F3 and
okay this plan is still coming but but I
think the queen on C8 would be I mean
wouldn't I be taking I it it feels like
feels like maybe this check was a little
too um of knee-jerk
reaction okay well I age with you that
he could have played this more precisely
but he doesn't have much time so this is
the reason why he's not making the best
moves I I was just going to say if it
Carl holds this a big part of it will
again be because of time I I agree with
you so um okay gregorians is still up a
pawn and a pawn is a pawn and here they
come right two two two versus one that
is how we get past pawns he's going to
advance and get a pass pawn and get a
new Queen everybody so so I think Serge
still goes on po7 Bishop poor Bishop the
other Bishop was even worse of course
but this G7 Bishop is not doing anything
either
MH check town oh yeah car just throws in
the towel there okay well the lead stays
at three and we have a lot lot more
people playing Guess the move after I
announced it so again thank you
everybody again though Jay Cal's chess
is winning he's somebody needs to
Dethrone J cow's chess because he is
right there at the top with this time
getting 13 of 39 Guess the move on every
game
here there we go well done well done to
him and uh also well done to Sergey for
this for this game he has outplayed
Hikaru it was a very nice positional way
of getting advantage in the Ros Lio yeah
agree and that brings us back to our to
our scoreboard here and and what we have
is um a a three-game lead after it is
updated the team is team is updating it
there we go we see only a three- game
lead 8 to five in the total score you
can also see the score right here next
to the players names if you can see
where my mouse is down here you can also
see the score um that's carrying over
there so uh if you're following in the
chess.com live server it's easy to
follow we call that a grudge match score
one of the coolest inventions we ever
did so you can see I think we did it
because guys like Nakamura or Yakov
norowitz or people would log on to
chess.com and play four hours of
straight chess against some random
opponent right watching hikaro destroy
Eric Hansen sorry Eric we love you but
we know watching hikaro win those
matches you know 86 to five or something
that's that's why we invented those
things so we can see the running
totals um all right well hikaro is is
again night on be okay but this time
it's Theory actually and this time it's
a little different I know but I'm happy
yeah it's an open Center here everybody
and the night is not as bad there is
normally remember what we highlighted
about the night being bad is that it's
usually it's usually bad when it's
eating Granite right we talked about how
all those squares were were guarded or
occupied by white pawns okay so here's a
little better but remember your Russian
school boy knowledge don't put your
Knights on B6 in those closed
positions um okay 904 so we have an
English here it's an English that turns
into one of those vers Dragon looking
positions and this is still Theory so
the players are well prepared though
Sergey is down on time so he made the
best moves but thinking a bit more than
Hikaru yeah indeed hearo uh almost
looked a little disinterested there with
the yawn perhaps thinking about his
appearance on on Bloomberg and his stock
trades and and uh something else but uh
okay is that the first snack we've seen
no that was that was a drink I keep
waiting for the first one to bust out
snacks we know when Maxim plays he'll
have a schoras board of treats available
to
himself uh but hiar doesn't normally eat
during these things that's just that's
good that I think that's relatively what
does he have is is that chocolate or I'm
I'm trying to figure it out I'm trying
to figure it out I thought I think he
just swished it around it might have
just been a red bulll or some
water all right everybody
so what's the evaluation here it's
pretty much equal it's it's a lot like a
reversed E4 game here um if you're a
sicilian player you you probably okay I
was expecting maybe C5 would have been
very much like a reverse maroxy bind um
but but Ser elected not to play that but
in this position it's not is not so
recommendable with the fiano bishop the
G2 Bishop would have been more powerful
right so Sergey trying to maybe launch a
plan where this Knight can come to E6
and eventually into the weakness on D4
but feels like White's a little bit head
in in the race for that kind of thing
right yeah he wants to push D4 so Rook
D1 and next move can be D4 already and
if the position opens up then white will
be slightly better well I think black is
going to put the Knight into D4 and the
question is how does white want to deal
with that no he doesn't do it right away
oh he's got a simply threatening Bishop
B3 yeah and Hikaru Hikaru might have
missed that it's not of course it's not
a difficult move but he was somewhat
surprised
by the sight of
A4 well the chair Shuffle tells us that
right a little bit of a also all right
all right all right I missed that I need
to I need to you know buckle up here and
and sit up so he he does that
um he's been rocking the head look at
this this is this is Russian
technique look at that he's trading off
his bad Bishop his bad dark Square
Bishop to
ensure
he gave up a pawn in order to give up
that bishop and get the D4 Square so he
prevented the D4 push and now he has a
better bishop and active pieces so that
was for the sacrifice of a pawn I agree
but I I'm worried that okay I mean if he
allows D4 don't be surprised if Nakamura
I almost thought maybe he should have
just gone for it but I do like que D7
but maybe he had to go for this in order
to play Rook C8 still if you have to do
it then the pawn sacrifice
exactly yeah if he if he if he's
allowing D4 then the whole thing was
bogus because um as you said the whole
point was that black had a grip that he
no longer
has
um yeah whites up a pawn it's not the
not the cleanest Pawn you've ever had at
least not right oh look at that such a
good move he's going to relocate
eliminate Black's mind and you saw you
saw Sergey kind of shake his head as
he's doing now frustrated frustrated
with his approach to this position um
yeah it's understandable
this is just a bad position with a pawn
down and he's down in the match
so yeah we're back we're back to a
three-game lead so he still has never
crossed that we've never ever seen a
comeback line of five games but he's
teetering on the edge right he's
teetering on the edge with about how
much time do we have left about 25
minutes in the the 3-2 portion so um you
know sometimes these first round B
matchups with the qualified players are
a little bit lopsided I guess I mean of
course these are super super strong
Grand Masters like gregorians but when
you're going up against the world's best
sometimes it just gets really hard in a
match setting it's not an open Swiss
format where you're changing opponents
it's it's one man who you got to take on
and it's and you know that can be real
tough that that is really tough you got
the point that in an open tournament if
you lose a game against a strong Grand
Master next game you will have somebody
weaker but here you face the same Beast
every game yep and a beast they are now
we've got title players all up in the
guest the move love that Grand Master JY
JY I love that National Master penguin
ninja I love that so tons of players
someone did
Dethrone um the uh the man who I was
talking about uh is is not even in the
top 10 this round sorry buddy not not
trying to pick on you but I did I ruined
your dominance V Panda 64 you've been
pretty consistent I guess the move shout
out to you buddy so if you log in to
chess.com and follow the games live you
can guess the moves before the players
play them and um we have our we have a
Berlin at this point we can probably
guess that the Berlin might be coming in
some of the cases because uh we've seen
it a few times now hey car nakam moris
camera Dro there hopefully he can be
reminded of that but Anna what do we
think what what what does Sergey need to
do to to change the tempo of what we're
watching is it possible good question I
think the opening choice is fine because
he was getting good positions from the B
um and in terms of the match play faster
because he's getting really down on time
the problem is that with this match uh
the match format is that the more games
he loses the less confident he is and
that means that he's going to play even
slower because if you're not confident
you just cannot make quick moves right
so difficult he has to he has to somehow
forget about the result of the match and
the play faster and play
Confident yeah agreed and emotionally
getting a hold of yourself is difficult
in these settings we say it every almost
every match as we start to see it slide
away um you know with the players are
really equally prepared and you got one
blow the other person delivers a blow
you don't see it as much but whenever
you lose a few games in a row it's just
it's just not fun right I mean
emotionally it it hurts and and uh in a
real tournament you would have a day off
you know you take a walk on the beach
you do something but here you're sort of
chain to your chair via the rules of
chess.com right the brutal rules of our
format and not a lot of time you got to
be able to pull yourself together
psychologically speed up and do those
things Anna is saying you know without
without uh without the the ability of
someone to remind you or to take a break
and refresh yourself so yeah yeah
exactly you are right uh of course Mike
is here once again with some great stats
and he's reminding us that uh while we
have seen many draws in the five minute
plus 2 second Blitz Games here there are
zero draws and every game has been won
by one white so that's good news for
Sergey if he can win this game and not
lose the next one that would be the way
to change this formula and not always
give the victory to White that's true
well he's got to win this one first to
avoid falling into that five game hole
um you know he's done well in the Berlin
I kind of like the way this Berlin is
headed uh once again for white F6 Square
available for the Knight um and this
Knight maneuver not allowing Bishop
takes f
three yeah um this is uh I almost feel
like Caro maybe should have taken last
turn while he had the chance um but he
didn't he played Rook to G8 hoping to
get the open lines for the rook and
Bishop but now gregorians has has put
the kibos on that guarding G4 and I
think even moves like F3 kind of anchor
it in Knight to G4 King F2 just look at
that right it's like a super solid brick
wall You Got This brilliant Pawn on E5 I
like gregorians to to win this one I
think F3 is the move that makes the most
sense and then and then start to start
to bring pieces out yeah I think he has
great chances he went for rook d8 and N9
G4 which is also a great plan of course
he has multiple ways of playing this
position but maybe your F3 move with
have cored Bishop
e4a why why it's a common idea here
usually it's not a move I came up with
on my own without seeing it before this
is a common thing when the Knight comes
back they play a three yes you're
putting your pawns on light squares that
are potential targets to this bishop but
that's such a long-term issue that it
never rarely becomes a reality the white
king gets active so um now now Sergey
has the deal with the C2 pawn and then
the the C6 square has been opened up for
the Knight so that could have been an
inaccuracy by him not to not to kind of
put the full strangle hold on on black
there and now he's taking his time so if
this one doesn't work out again for
vorian he may he may look back and wish
he played this
move true I I agree with you that now he
he regrets not having played
F3 so he goes back to D2 but this yeah
no way you're happy to do that right I
mean no he still has F6 but but now this
bishop has a new home where all all that
you want to do when you're worse in
these positions you have less space
everybody is to do what Nakamura is
doing often it's about uh you know
making a timely trade to give your
pieces more squares you don't want your
pieces wrestling over squares like C6
where both the bishop and the Knight
were sitting there so this is just you
know an important resource by black and
and and perhaps a critical mistake by
sery not to prevent
it his back so we can once again show
his face he realized that his camera was
off he he's got the fan blowing in his
wind let's get hikaro to give us like a
model head shake you know where he kind
of shakes his head and lets the fan you
know hair blow his I used to have long
hair as a kid believe it or not my
mother did that Ash emotional scaring um
but uh yeah believe it I did have I did
have long hair but uh it was more of
like a mullet I think like children who
were born in the 80s when their parents
like who kind of came from being hippies
Anna um they they just like they did
things like that like they they had
their let their kids have mullets and
got emotionally scarred seriously get at
me on Twitter if your parents did this
to you as well you know and then you
look back at your family pictures and
you're like Mom I had a mullet bro like
what was wrong with you right um anyway
I don't know if your parents did that to
you you ever look like like my my and
with girl my wife she has pictures of
herself with a with like almost like a
bull cut like as a boy and it's like
hilarious we're like looking at the
haircut we're like what were you doing
like I didn't not have that I had a
haircut like CIA does the singer oh yeah
yeah yeah I'm telling
you that's nice that's super nice that
might turn things around round hi Caro
just gave the oh I'm disgusted with
myself number six yeah he was actually
not happy there yeah um he just he knows
he's is is he losing a piece after yeah
takes G6 if you take back he gets E5 and
and black can't get both the Knight on
H5 and the bishop on E5 and T oh but
there's there's Knight F3 check at the
end of it so after takes if Nakamura
goes for this line Anna yeah there's a
threat of Knight F3 check oh wait he
still gets it
okay gorian sa he's still going to be up
a piece looks like he has this move Rook
D5 to avoid the fork and hikaro is
scratching his head so he might need to
he might need to turn away from this
Berlin I mean we kind of called it Mike
Mike with the stats and like we said the
Berlin has been has been a position that
gregorians has proven he can play with
with the best in the world and he's
beaten Nakamura and he's about to do it
again exactly so in the end of the day
this is a piece up for Sergey he calcul
CED very well the complications after
Bishop B4 and went for
F5 uh there's just no chance that he can
save this the only fact the only factor
that works for black is the time 23
seconds left for Sergey but from now on
he will play very fast yeah Knight to G4
probably first before King G6 I think um
yeah he does it yeah I think he'll win
and I I think that if one thing if we
were assessing the overall match
Direction here anna real quick I think
we'd say that Sergey has done well with
E4 right remember before this nice win
in the Berlin he won in the Rosal Lio
and before that he won in the Berlin so
he with this E4 approach I wonder if
he's regretting the sort of D4 approach
he had early in the match right I mean
he's he's won he's won several games now
as
white so maybe that's a question we can
ask him afterwards if if he if he
changed because he just kind of didn't
get what he was wanting to get in those
D4 games and and um you know it seemed
to work out for him so far yeah I I
would right it down before I forget it
I'm I don't know about you but I'm
capable of forgetting all my questions
during the R I forget everything I can't
even remember what you're writing down
right now that's literally where I'm at
so go for it I'm glad you wrote it down
um no but in all in all seriousness okay
you know Caro is doing well here he's
defending down a piece and you got the
rook in the Knight that is the most
impotent Duo rook and Knight versus Rook
so if uh if a Caro can just find some
way to Swindle off a pawn trade he would
once again hold a position he had no
business holding but I don't think he
will I think gregorians will get this
one yeah he should but this is this is
more difficult than it
seemed check M something's going on here
if C5 we have Rook C6 and things are
getting weird
huh still defending the PA from the
fifth
rank he has only eight seconds on the
clock and even though this position is
win winning it is not as easily winning
as a previous position could have been
so we thought that his position was just
yeah look at that now his Pawn is being
traded his L Pawn oh my gosh iaro did do
it he found a way to Swindle the
defense amazing and that's incredible
Hikaru was a simply a pce town he has
managed to get this draw
position yeah no that's amazing and
hikaro is scratching his head he's
making it look easy for all of us I mean
this is uh super impressive right now um
only 15 minutes left in the 3 minute
portion so you know if if this is a
telling of the tides the other way we we
were calling for a victory by by
Gregorian and that he would bring it
once again back to three games and have
a chance but but if this stays at four
games Anna and then you give Nakamura
the white pieces again that that the
trend we've been seeing that Mike Klein
highlighted would show that Nakamura
could take a five-game lead and and
really start to put this thing away
before the bullet portion yeah we might
see that coming and I don't think that
Hikaru will blunder his rook and that's
basically the only way you can lose this
unless you bring your king to the edge
of the board which will Hikaru not do
either it's so funny because we had we
had the title Tuesday and remember you
and I saw multiple of these right we saw
The Rook rook and and we saw hikaro win
with the rook and Knight versus a rook
in one game which was just super
impressive um so gregorians is doing
some weird stuff he's doing this thing
where the Knight kind of comes forward
everybody it guards a checking Square so
Nakamura Rook you know F you know can't
can't continue to check um and then he
hopes that he can use that kind of theme
to you to maybe maybe push the king and
the King over to the edge of the board
at some
point but it really takes cooperation
you that's why these games are drawn as
we've just seen because you just you
need cooperation you need blunders to
win those games games and if you're
gregorians that's an opportunity lost
right there uh we now have a a four game
lead maintained 9 and 1 half 5 and a
half will be the score as soon as it's
updated and
um and with it Nakamura now has the
white pieces again look what he's doing
he's going into bullet chess nakam he's
already preparing for his bullet chess
approach which is going to be crazy
opening
hikaro so this is the last no no they
still have plenty of games to play 14
minutes left
yep so plenty of time left um how we
doing on Twitter we getting anything
creative come on guys like take a
picture of yourself watching the stream
like as you I don't know like do gym
class or um you know I don't you know
yeah there are many creative ones
actually for instance Alexander has
tweeted that he's projecting the screen
onto the ceiling so he's watching us
from the ceiling of his house so he can
lay down first of all why do I not have
a TV on my ceiling that is a genius idea
that like I mean half time when you're
laying in bed the biggest problem is you
have to Crane your neck and look forward
you should just have the TV up there
thank you that is who else that's
awesome yeah there are some awesome
tweets I I will have trouble picking
three of you guys and Danny you should
let me know how will we give them the
price if they let us know their
usernames yeah just they'll they'll just
tweet at tweet at me tweet at you our
usernames and we'll get it to
them we'll good for it so yeah just if
you get if you win Anna will contact you
and then we'll get you your diamond
membership and anyway even if you
already have a diamond membership show
us show us some fun time so um all right
well uh what's going on here we we
uh we have a new opening not a Kings
Indian attack right yeah well old new
opening of Hikaru starting with
B3 and this position has actually
transformed into something looking very
traditional yep
um and
uh it's it's almost a maroxy bind for
white without the pawn on e4 but if
black can do something before white
completes a full strength hold maybe
maybe black wants to strike with D5 but
the problem is that Knight A4 comes in
with Tempo and probably there's some
weakness on these dark squares here and
maybe that's why he plays Queen B8 he
wants to get the queen away from being
Tempo so that he can try to try to do
something here in the center um yeah I
was going to say the same that you
mentioned that even though Black's
position is comfortable it's not easy to
do something because d5s always weaken
the C5 Square so he goes for C5 but
what's next after this and now we have
the D5 square and and uh the I thing I
was saying is look at the time not
because one player is under time
pressure but because Nakamura hasn't
even used us he's used two seconds total
in the game on move on move 18 so he's
uh he's playing very very fast uh and
and gregorians has some issues to figure
out here how do I deal with the coming
threats of D5
occupation I don't know I mean I was
just asking rhetorically because I don't
know what black is supposed to do here
um well if he can trade many pieces then
it won't be that bad so yeah I was just
going to say maybe he goes maybe he goes
for 94 and um you know as long as
there's no tactics once the king gets G7
because white can capture white can
capture on G7 the king will be there on
a diagonal but there's no doesn't like
there's any tacticos there so Black is
Black is doing okay
um 94 looks like a decent a decent move
Carl not quite getting anything concrete
now
what does he think about that what does
his face say his face says he still
thinks he's better for
sure um and now maybe maybe he tries to
open things up yeah there was the
headbob he might even go for G4 now I'm
wondering if he's going to play King of
two and G I almost think King of2 and G4
was better and look at all of Black's
major pieces stuck on the queen side I
would have loved to have see could see
that coming and that's that's not a joke
actually that the white can go for King
F2 G4 you are completely right that all
the black pieces are stuck on the queen
side yeah um Queen be for good move you
should get rid of the Queens but he will
not he wants to but now aaro's actually
starting to just sack on on H5 in some
positions and and yeah blow open the
king with the queen entering so this has
become very tough and above all else
again I okay that's going to be too slow
I don't know if he's going to play
Knight takes but he might just play
G4 I think Nakamura goes on to win this
one in a mating attack fashion I'm
calling it here
but you know I think the biggest thing
is that the the time disadvantage so he
goes for for my suggestion but the
bottom line is that even if this was
defendable Anna doesn't have the time to
do it you're right yeah once again he's
two minutes uh he he coverage two
minutes up on the clock Sergey only has
half a minute so bad time management and
also his position is inferior this is
not looking good for
Sergey yeah well he's going to find ways
to get attacking chances on the on the
B3 pawn and that's nice
uh but yeah and the way he did it was
pushing H4 so he gave up the H Pawn in
order to keep the king side more or less
closed I agree and it was the smartest
idea because we were we were looking at
the H file becoming open with mating
attacks or you know God forbid the G
file black would have been dead but uh
you know he did the best thing he could
do handling that position everybody CU
he gave up the pawn and kept kept the
position close so
um you know uh he's actually you know
he's defended and hikaro was calculating
here using using time really for the
first time in the game
um yeah because
Black's Black's plan is very clear you
just want to double Rooks on the B5 put
as much pressure on the B3 Pawn as
possible also Bishop A4 at some point
could be a possibility if you pin
everything yeah um he may have to settle
on something like Knight G2 and then put
the Rook on D3 and as ugly as that looks
to have three major pieces on the third
rank defending one little guy I think
that if there's no follow up there for
black then he can slowly kind of build
up F4 and F five oh no so hikaro says
yeah Danny you don't know what you're
talking about I'm going to go for mate
right now okay well good job hikaro I
was testing you buddy I was testing you
aaro
um uh actually this looks like white is
just blowing things
open Rook takes B3 trying to create
counterplay but doesn't look
enough hi car doesn't think it's enough
either he's got number five going number
five kind of squirly like little bit of
nose he's like h i don't buy it you got
a lot of Praise in the chat by the way
you managed to read his facial
expressions is everybody says that you
are an expert on Hikaru I am I am an
expert on Hikaru I only claim to be an
expert on three things um and neither
one none of those three is chess but uh
one I'll let the I'll let the fans think
about that one but one of them is aaro
Nakamura facial
expressions U maybe we should have aaro
do all his facial expressions and I
could be like his conscience and kind of
like be speaking his thoughts you know
that could be fun and
weird I think that would be a a great
new St style of Chess so you should
develop that idea further and that could
be a chess variety yeah yeah chess
conscious like your chess conscience hi
I'm your chess conscience we haven't we
haven't spoken in a while hi hi Caro I'm
your conscience we haven't spoken in a
while and uh I think you're doing great
buddy all right well look at that move
Queen F6 that's now with the H4 and the
F3 Pawn but yeah the past Pawn will
decide anyway the game I think he I
think he'll he'll get drawing chances
though yeah I mean he just is able to
take it
yeah yeah I I don't see a I don't see an
immediate win he's going to Che he play
as he'll play King G2 I think yeah and
just so aaro is still in the driver seat
guarding the pawns and and up a pawn but
uh yeah maybe it's still more losing for
Sergey than I
thought two pawns is no
fun yeah and he cannot really create uh
the possibility of giving Perpetual the
queen can go go back if necessary but
also a centralized Queen will always
cover many squares like the E5 square is
a key
here well we're hoping for the sake of
Statistics that uh that gregorians finds
a way to Swindle a draw here that would
keep it within the 4 game deficit he
would get white again one more time
before the three-minute portion was up
um and um you know he wouldn't have
crossed that Ah that's it he lost right
as I say it he blunders the queen trade
and that is it um with the Queens off
the board this is going to be easy King
and pun ending so so you know we're
getting into that territory
unfortunately where Gregorian is is kind
of just being outmatch and obviously
these you know he deserves a ton of
credit for even getting here but right
now this is kind of slipping away from
him and and the bullet isn't even here
yet and everybody knows how aaro is in
bullet
um so and if you don't know I said
everybody knows which means you should
know so that's that's the way we should
think about it um so we have five
minutes left does it mean that this will
be the last three well we have to wait
see how quickly the game ends I mean if
if something happens quickly and someone
blunders then um then no they would play
one more but otherwise stay tuned
everybody right when this is over we
will have our next chess 960 game the
last one didn't disappoint that was that
was a blasty MC blasters and so let's
see if we get that again sery has
switched back to one D4 after having
played E4 very
successfully that's I'm surprised by
that although this is better than the
games he was getting with the the
completely
no yeah but this is still a very
theoretical position in the open Catalan
which leads almost hope is to very jowi
position well he was he was trying to
repeat how Wesley so beat hikaro
Nakamura in this exact line right it
true some so that was his preparation
trying to
cais isn't everybody's preparation these
days to just try to play like Wesley so
everybody's preparation these days is
what what would Wesley do
wwwd what would Wesley so
do um I don't remember where this one
varied I just remember I just know that
that was the last theoretical game I had
on my memory of this line was so so's
victory over
Nakamura yeah I'm not sure either I I
know the game you are referring to but I
don't know if they are still following
it I think they they do because this is
a very theoretical maneuver the queen
coming to B5 so the point is that black
has an awfully ugly Pawn structure on
the Queen side like he was a pawn up and
now with Queen B5 he's trying to
straighten his Pawn chain right so no
longer up a pawn but um has healed his
structure that's what black has done uh
and the A5 Pawn is overextended so
there's some issues where this Pawn may
come under Fire in some lines if you
play B4 maybe B4 is weak so in a perfect
world white would be developed and get
the C file and and grab the initiative
but this is one of those things where
both sides are kind of like one move too
short of a perfect setup Anna
um and Sergey is is thinking a little
bit here hiar Nakamura is up hiar
Nakamura currently has more time than
which he started with um he just crossed
under the three minute oh he's got a car
on number you see that he had a car
number seven The Look Away did he yeah
look away over the shoulder where he
knew he's better but he's trying to
remember Theory number seven is is the
Look Away over the shoulder where he's
remembering Theory that's the specific
thing he's trying to remember how he
wants to play The Line
oh oh okay which one was that he made
like Taylor Swift and he shook off I
think he's no big deal that's something
you the Taylor Swift look the Taylor the
Taylor Swift Shake It Off look um all
right yeah well really he was upset
everybody that he played Rook C8 and
then had to play Rook A8 to guard the A6
pawn and suddenly white has achieved the
goals I was kind of talking about white
is white is ahead of the game on the C
file here but
uh hold the
phone yeah with that trade now it's will
white get more pressure before black
gets the king here and I'm going to
guess no and gorian I'm starting to
learn his facial expression I think he's
a little he's calculating now and I'm
not sure he's thrilled with the timing
of this position because here comes the
king run by
Nakamura um and I I actually he can't
break his Knight the problem is that he
do never get Knight B before yeah he
several moves short there now Nakamura
has choices do I give up C7 for A5 or I
think probably just forget about that
and bring the king h no I'm wrong he
decides he does want that and he guards
the ace guards the C7 OPP with Rook A7
that's creative yeah just to tie down
the Knight to the B3 Square yeah look at
that a knight once again breaking the
Russian school boy Uncle yero must be
freaking out right now about this match
I mean he must just not be happy with
sergey's willingness to break that
Russian school boy and on that note uh
we are uh speaking of willingness we're
willing to move on to 960 it's time I'm
going to let the players know that this
will be their last game
um so this is likely to end in a draw
the position doesn't seem to be
advantages for anyone let's not forget
about the time situation Sergey is down
to a minute and Hikaru always has two
and a half minutes on the clock I don't
know how he does that it doesn't matter
how many moves he has made he always has
time it's magical I agree it's I told
you I have had theories I am yet to be
proven on this that hero hakar Nakamura
is indeed hero Nakamura from the show
Heroes and he lives in a time travel
warp and the rest of us are just trapped
in it um so he he's constantly up on
time because he's basically he's almost
almost cheating you know he's up he's up
on time and uh and also and also time
traveling camera yeah he's time
traveling so I mean notice that notice
that my suspicions right he just
disappeared from the camera he just went
to time travel
hikaro get it together buddy if you're
going to keep your identity a secret you
got to be a little more you know a
little more cautious than
that all right but uh no he still has a
ton of
time white lacks a concrete way to
increase this Advantage despite the good
knight but I do like oh he he takes it
he he didn't like he didn't like the
idea of letting Sergey keep that Knight
either um goes for The Rook ending but
White's a little better here I mean if
you trade Rooks now hikaro has already
traded from one Rook impon ending into a
lost King impon ending we'll see if he
does it again I think now he's more
cautious about more cautious about doing
that okay after the king moves he'll
play H5 and then it's okay H5 or not
he's going to completely lock up the
position and we will have a draw so
um so
indeed yeah the only target would be the
G6 B but then Rook G8 even though it's
passive there's just no way to improve
the position sag is trying with E4 mhm
but it still doesn't lead to a position
that he can break yeah I mean black can
just like sit with the Rook on the most
passive sores possible and hiar was
doing that just Rook G7 Rook G8 and
Bob's your uncle it's over
um and I I think we will just see a draw
we will see a five game lead for
Nakamura heading into the next uh chess
960 battle which will be now Nakamura
will get the white pieces cuz he was
black um he is currently black in this
final thre minute game everybody which
means he will get white in chess 960 so
we'll see what our senior editor Pete
has in store for us I'm excited to see
this chess 960
position and he coverters back from his
time travel
so travel The Jig Is up he got caught
that's right buddy I'm on to you and
your time travel always up on time on
the clock on chess.com I'm tired of
these Shenanigans um
all right well this is just a draw
they're boring right now they're boring
us so let's come up with some jokes or
something let's remind people all right
no CH 960 yay here we
go yes all right so again if you're if
you're with us everybody so the the end
of the 3-2 started with a a five or it
ended with a f minute deficit I should
say for gregorians AAR Nakamura takes a
five-game lead into the bullet or at
least into the chess 960 battle and now
we get random chess so uh do we need to
explain the rules of Chess 960 again for
if there are newcomers who are new to
chess chess 960 is Rand let do it also I
I'm still puzzled by what happens with
the King on G1 now there's no castling
no there is castling you just you just
you just put your King on H1 and The
Rook will go to F1 okay so that's cing
that's castling so any no again like no
matter what unless the king and Rook
have moved breaking the traditional
rules or unless there's you know unless
there's a check or something right I
mean other than traditional rules there
is always a way to Castle regardless of
the PE setup in chess
960 and if you're wondering how
everybody again you just you just put
your King on top of the rook and and
they will the king that's how you
physically do it and and the pieces will
move so um and he may even do it on the
next move we'll see if he decides to get
castled it would kind of make sense here
to to recova kot
karova uh let's see yeah but then if you
Castle the H7 and the H2 paes will be
pretty weak so yeah on the other hand
how do you activate that Rook this this
is such a weird position he may decide
to mix it up maybe he plays H4 you could
be right and he decides hey what oh
there's no Rook on anyone look at my
brain right I'm used to playing normal
chess and I'm like what like he blunders
a he blunders a skew of the queen and
Rook oops there is no Rook there this is
chess
um okay I still expect one of these
players to get castled at some point
soon as they're done foing around
um C4 by the way those of you here in
the chat who are very about Sergey that
the match is already lost he still has
quite a lot to fight for because the
prices are
divided the depending on the percentage
of the points they score so every Point
matters that's a great point and and and
again everybody the uh the big thing is
you know obviously if if if in what we
expect happens in the remaining portion
of this match and Nakamura moves on to
face the winner of Fabiano Carana and ho
yon uh gregorians could still take away
several hundred dollars more than he
might take and maybe even I mean if he
went on a tear and you know won the
bullet portion somehow um you know that
uh that that could deliver some more
cash in his pocket which is fun I think
more tournaments should do that I mean
instead of like having just prize funds
I know I'm obviously touting my own
system here but I mean like why don't
over theboard tournaments also prevent
grandmas draws in the only way Anna
money talks and we know what walks which
is I think you're completely right you
you are totally right that this system
of giving out prices in in terms of the
percentage of the players that they
score of course there's a fixed price
plus this percentage depending on how
many points they score so I think it
makes a lot of sense well I guess the
grand CH chestor does it now right in
terms of the overall point standings one
turn after another but but in terms of
tournament to tournament that isn't
necessarily the case right um yeah
anyway so here we go this is interesting
we have a symmetrical structure on
either side really with any weaknesses
pawns equal but but white has white has
a small Edge probably in terms of a
space Advantage here some weirdness
going on with the Knights I don't know
but this is this is like you never this
position you know say it's chess 960 I
was just going to yeah exactly this is
once again as you said it doesn't take
long for it to look like a normal chess
game and okay right after this we will
have one more break and uh and uh and
that's
it um getting set for the next time
control to start here
bullet the bullet portion you guys
should predict in the chat and also on
Twitter if you are tweeting with the
hashtag speeches how do you think Sergey
will do in bullet because in theory
that's the best uh for Hikaru isn't that
he is considered to be the best bullet
player in the world uh we we could argue
whether it's Magnus or Hikaru but
certainly that's number one and number
two spot in terms of uh bullet and also
well under Blitz rating list but bullet
especially online for Hikaru that's
something that he is the one who created
bullet online for sure he's probably
played more bullet games than than I've
played like all other time controls
combined I mean he's he's played he's
played more so hikaro has played a lot
of bullet chest like he makes 10 the
10,000 hours Theory you know look like
Child's Play he has spent a lot of time
playing bullet chest I mean honestly it
may not be healthy I mean let's be
totally honest how much time he has
spent playing bullet chess so you know
but okay hicaro is uh is very good at
what he does and we'll see how Sergey
holds up and and stacks up in the in the
fastest time control of the
match uh all right well the Knights are
going to be all that's left I'm guessing
after a big trade here anna Rooks on the
open file are coming off oh nope D I was
wrong I think aaro did that on purpose
um but he's actually got a threat there
everybody the reason is that there was a
threat of Knight to E6 Fork Town
um but actually that really makes a lot
of sense Jokes Aside about why hikaro
did that because now now that there's
some open Line weaknesses he's going to
switch to the defile with Tempo and
black us for yeah exactly yeah they're
silly over there I
agree
[Music]
um the funny thing is that the Black
Knight is also coming to C4 so there
will be a similar setup those are the
outposts for the Knight where's hikara
again he's traveling all the time
yep uh Pete Pete in a conversation with
peace 555 in the game chat with uh
quoting quoting Good Fellas there saying
that Danny wrench is fun like a clown
like he amuses you that's right that's
right so anyway that's a that's a Joe
pesi line you're not going to get a pop
culture reference by me nice try buddy
um all right so yeah now Nakamura is
really bringing the heat because the
king is kind of wandered into open
territory trouble can can you say
F yeah he wants to go Knight C4 so there
is no immediate win because the The Rook
will be hanging but this this feels like
trouble yeah it's feels like something
has gone wrong here um so I forgot to
say funniest to my 8-year-old last night
Anna you'll love look at there sorry
then you have to tell me but
what GNN the win the night after King E7
Rook A6 the Knight has no defense ah
hold on ah but he gets F4
anyway and he will have time to take the
B5 Pawn if you go Rook
E8 yeah it's uh it's going to be a
winning rook and pawn ending not not a
rook and pawn ending that has too much
drawing chances and if we look at the
clock Gregorian says yeah is surviving
only on the increment currently well but
now do you see a win for white I
don't okay quick line if takes
everything do I have Rook C5 just
throwing it out there no I don't okay
hikaro says no I thought maybe there
were some weird way no du I mean he has
a pone up of course but I thought that
Hikaru might have had something more
with that suspicious e file so actually
Sergey is still still trying he still
has a chances of drawing this
game yeah uh he doesn't have a lot of
time on the clock to draw the game but
if he can if he can find a quick setup
at this point you have to be doing two
things which is why it's so hard to be
under time pressure everybody you have
to play accurate moves with what's in
front of you clearly as in every chess
game but Ser has to do he just so short
on time yeah Sergey also has to do a
good job of trying to visualize a good
defensive setup a setup that he could
actually hold against the different
tries which is thinking bigger picture
like that Anna like where you're kind of
evaluating the essence of the position
he lost did you see that gesture by
Hikaru yeah yeah he this as soon as uh
as soon as he won Hikaru immediately
jumped out of his chair once again he
enjoys his break we will remind Sergey 3
minute break right now um and the chess
960 portion is over but what I was
saying in is it's so hard you know like
under time pressure like that when
you're when you're winning it's easier
but if you're defending you have to
think about the big picks your goals of
what is the ideal defensive setup and
make accurate moves against it's just so
hard to do that kind of critical
thinking you know without any time
you're completely right and with only
two a two second increment he had just
zero time and living out of the two
second increment is just an impossible
task so what is the score right now we
have a six-game lead for the American 12
to six in terms of the total games they'
played play uh including the chess 9960
game um so we have a a six-game lead
according to the scoreboard here
although the uh the score in chest.com
says 116 anyway we'll make sure but it's
it's a six-game lead I'm pretty sure and
um and Nakamura is in the driver's seat
that is an understatement a very
difficult task gregorians has ahead of
him hash Yoda by accident hash
accidental Yoda anyway Anna so last
night my eight-year-old tells me which
was awesome that he was paying attention
he goes dad so when did Magnus Carlson
get glasses oh so even he was paying
attention to magnus's New Direction
we'll call it in fact speaking of
Direction he kind of looks like somebody
from One Direction right actually I mean
a little bit maybe I mean he's got he's
got uh he's got kind of a hairy styles
thing going on with this new hairo and
the glasses somebody please share a
picture of what Magnus looks like
currently in the chat so I don't look
like an idiot as I'm talking about this
because
yeah you guys should have seen it I mean
this this is this is the Talk of the
Town Magnus C and getting glasses and
growing his hair uh he says that he has
a plan with his hair so we are all
puzzled by what is that plan what is
what is the the dimension that he
imagines growing out of his hair best
laid plans of Magnus and Men we'll
see
and we are getting some more pictures so
guys if you haven't tweeted us yet use
the hash speed chess take a picture of
where you are watching the match from is
it a mobile device is it your laptop is
it the TV screen your computer are you
at work are you at home is it during the
day is it by night you should let us
know where you are watching from by
using the hashtag speed chess and we
have three winners at the end of the
show I shall pick three it's going to be
a very difficult task because there are
so many great photos so keep them coming
# speed chess on
Twitter indeed I can't wait to see who
you choose as winners we'll review them
and uh it looks like we are getting set
to start the bullet portion and this is
the final half hour where the gloves as
if they've even been on they really come
off now and um the bullet portion has
begun yeah uh this is going to be uh
very interesting to see whether Hikaru
can increase his Advantage even further
I think he will the question is by how
many points but according to Mike uh
this will not be the largest win in
history Magnus won
21-4 in the opening round last year
that's right and it was it was
mind-blowing petan uh tigron petan not
the late world champion but the uh the
the new tigon
petan was awesome in the qualifier and
and did so great and and when you go up
against Magnus I don't know things just
don't always work out you know and when
you play Magnus Carlson um and so as far
as the time goes we have again uh the
the uh the match clock is
ticking we are we have just we have just
jumped in here the 30 minutes remaining
in this match will be all bullet all fun
so uh if you've been with us for the
whole show first of all I just I love
you I mean really I do I mean thanks for
the support everybody who's now follow
who's now followed our channel uh make
sure you stick around and look for those
alerts obviously we have a lot going on
on chess TV but we also have the next
match uh going down with with uh Sergey
karakan and gorg Meyer on May 24th
followed immediately that's why I have
to say it because there won't be a lot
of time to talk about the next match and
that is of course aniri and Wesley so I
just cannot wait for that Wesley is is
so good right now I know that but I I
feel like Gary's you know I got to take
Wesley's the favorite in that match real
quick Anna because Wesley's also played
a lot more on chess.com than Anish has I
mean
he favorite by the way have you done
your
bracket I didn't fill out my bracket in
time just I was I was silly I was
traveling yesterday and I so it's I'll
probably cheat and let them enter my
bracket afterwards I mean spoiler alert
I would I would have taken Nakamura in
this match anyway so I I I would doubt I
mean how many people took rorian in this
match against Nakamura nothing against
Sergey but obviously we're dealing with
AAR Nakamura here yeah of course Hikari
is the heavy favorite I have done my
brackets and I've pick Nakamura and uh
also I picked the vesley H so yeah we
will see who is going to win it's going
to be great watch we need to do another
bracket challenge let let's let's see it
you got to send me your bracket I'll do
my bracket I would have had Nakamura
today anyway so I'm a little late but
I'll do my bracket and um yeah and then
we should do a bracket show you are
right yeah that'll be fun to break down
the
matchups um all right
well he's keeping up with time right now
Sergey is and in fact this position is
is is wild and weird um
but okay x's and nose I do like white
yes yes I do I mean Black's King is wide
open I think I think I do like white as
well because it feels like there's
something concrete but in the end of the
day is it enough I was just going to say
Here Comes D5 and this is going to be
that was like a after D5 yes I I was
looking for the the way to break through
I think he had D6 with a mate coming on
E7 he didn't go for it that's what I
would have
probably um but okay he still has the
pressure and even even uh with only 12
seconds it doesn't matter because his
opponent only has four and yeah Sergey
has a a bad position I mean sorry no he
has a good position but he's going to
lose in time that's what I was going to
say maybe he's not okay he's he's riding
on the increment he's doing it you're
doing it Sergey going to some time he's
doing it Rook takes A5 you're oh hi Caro
that was the authentic oh my God that's
number six as we said disgusted with
himself actually just purely not happy
um
oh but he gets G2 and he hopes for a
draw no he can't take it he's got to try
to do something with the king in the
open board
um but Sergey is going to strike first
in the bullet ladies and gentlemen don't
go anywhere you you wouldn't want to be
the one who missed the most epic
comeback of all time W I completely
forgot that they have an increment I
thought it was just one zero that's why
I was saying that he's gonna lose on
time so how many seconds are increment
one- one only one yeah one every
everything else is 3-2 but it's it's
one1 yeah wow he managed to build up
quite some
time yeah and he wins and he strikes
first and on that down score is
bullet against the best bullet player in
the world this isn't over let's see what
happens all right so we're back to a
five-game lead we know that usually the
bullet portion has about as many games
as the other two sections combined um
often and um and so we will we'll see
how many games they get but certainly
Sergey needs a lot of games and a lot of
points in order to come back and now
he's playing Black against uh hikara
Nakamura and that's never fun
um in fact this already looks things are
getting a little weird here
what oh he's got a weird idea where he
sacks a piece temporarily but that
Bishop on C4 is not going to be able to
save itself and keep yeah two pieces
hanging at the same time so he's getting
it back ugly Pawn structure but active
pieces yeah C5 yeah not allowing C5 was
just a bad move yeah uh yeah it would
have been a good idea if you can hang
gone to the pawn but after dropping it
yeah hikaro not happy there quickly just
kind of be like all right that was that
was a conf confused after losing that
game yeah he's confused after losing the
game and I think that he was also um he
he kind of shook his head like knew he
was frustrated with himself but that was
a little bit of a I'm I'm going to get
it together just advice to everybody
watching like car was like all right all
right come on hikaro Focus here so
expect him to to kind of start turning
it on now a little bit like okay got to
get in your body
here wow Sergey gregorians we thought
that he had no chance at all in thei
Sergey Sergey Town population don't
blunder oh oh and he blunders away the
game but I told you that that confident
headshake was a Caro like all right stop
messing around put away this match and
um and he he he immediately started
playing very very well despite being
down upon Pawn there he outplayed
outplayed black yeah he's doing it he's
getting this game wow this was this was
just
uh he kind seemed to be in trouble and
then he managed to pull himself together
and sery missed this night trick also
this could be the first I mean this is a
this is really going to challenge Mike
Klein's stat uh his his stat prowess I
think this is could be the first one
ever where the winner wins the game with
more time on the clock than which he
started with yep that all right Mike
that's a challenge for you go see if I'm
right about that buddy is that the first
time someone has won a game with more
time than which they started with in one
of these um one of these Blitz battles
speed chest this this uh this format
that we do here I'm curious I don't know
how he's going to find that out actually
he either knows it or he doesn't or he's
going to say he figured it out and I'm
going to believe him which is happens
all the time anyway I mean I'm sure most
of the stuff he tells
me I think he already has his answer let
me see it we'll see we'll see what did
he say uh I don't know if it's his
answer to this one but he says you
forgot laska versus laska in
1919 what did I forget Lasker versus
Lasker in 1919 I have no idea I don't
even know what that means I think he's
just is anything Mike Klein enjoys more
than the love he gets for being
funmaster Mike it's the it's delivering
a stat that blows people's minds and and
being a little bit more on you know he's
just Mike Mike is I'll put it this way
okay he's a he plays Fantasy Baseball d
d exactly all the fantasy baseball
players out there are like what is that
supposed to mean what is that supposed
to mean I'm like let me put it this way
baseball is boring and playing Fantasy
Baseball takes the most attention for
the for the four months of the Season by
the way I love baseball but it I'm going
to be honest with you it doesn't it's
not as fast-paced I mean chess is more
exciting than baseball yeah I said it
yeah okay I agree with you and he's
saying that of course he cannot research
that but he thinks he does remember it
happening he thinks it's happened before
yeah I wondered if Magnus maybe did it
before or someone but uh here we go with
the baseball stat in 1997 Greg Maddox
blah blah blah Mike Klein
delivered anyway no but seriously uh
baseball baseball is uh is Mike's
specialty he knows things that I like I
don't even I can't even explain him so
he knows everything about
baseball um so what about this position
after G5 look at that aggressive move
[Music]
I like hiar trying to open FS on the on
the king side because on the queen side
his position is pretty much dominated so
I like why it's Queen side but can we
leave this King Alone on G1 or is it
fast enough if you go Rook G8 and try to
bring the heavy pieces to the G5 or to
the F5 Queen F3 uhoh Knight C4 though OE
yeah the
fork got to play Rook to D3 and then oh
no he has another idea in mind very nice
uh no he's going to get a million and a
half pawns and does Sergey have a tactic
no I don't know that he does so somehow
hikaro swindles his way through
that oh and now he's he's going on to
win this for sure I mean this is too
many pawns now for a bite to deal with
the D Pawn is wait the D Pawn's falling
no yes
no that was a weird approach there by
aaro but I guess he assessed that the
queen side pawns would still be enough
he better run run run as fast as he
can uh I don't know that he calculated
that accurately because now if those
pawns are stopped I guess there's just
too you know what it is there's too many
there's pawns over here too he's just
black has pawns pass pawns on both both
sides of the board h and a and white
just can't catch up to him yeah um for
sure he had something better than this
but this should be good enough unless
white manages to get one of the black
pawns and sacrifice his Knight for the
remaining Pawn
yeah yeah it would take a sacrifice that
uh black didn't see
coming the corner
Pond well actually well no I don't think
he will manage but but he he gets close
to it yeah he is actually managing it
looks like he held yeah look King E5 no
he did yeah the the king is back he will
take the PA right now yeah wow okay well
that that happened really fast yeah and
honestly what's most impressive about
that is not just the draw but that he
did it in bullet while riding off the
increment right Anna I mean he was down
on time and he so cir showing he can he
can hang here with aaro and bullet which
is which is awesome yeah this is a one
and a half one and a half so far in the
bullet portion so he's doing very well
by the way have you realized that he has
taken off his
glasses oh he did take off his glasses I
didn't even notice that good good what
does that mean what does it mean I don't
I mean thank you right what does it all
mean basil yeah I don't know but it it's
something for us to talk about that
doesn't matter hashtag story of everyone
of my chess shows
um but uh okay now iaro is launching you
know it's kind of like a a Tory London
system but The Bishop's on B2 right so
he's going to play F4 and he wants to
get a big attack oh no he doesn't not
now he now he decides to transition into
getting the bishop pair not going to get
a Checkmate attack anymore but he does
have the bishop
pair but it's not over yet I mean
mathematically this match is not over if
Sergey finds a way to win this match
after holding that draw uh in the last
game Anna this is you know something
that's going to hold our attention to
the end
here you are right this is not over
anding bullet anything can happen if you
remember how started the bullet portion
very confidently winning and also in the
second game he was
winning yeah uh if he did not uh if he
did not blunder then he could have won
that game as well so anything can
happen and he's playing playing well
here I mean hikaro is up on time but you
know no surprise uh but but he's poking
at these at these weak Pawns and as you
get these pawns to advance they open up
new week squares like D5 I don't be
surprised if you see the knights try to
relocate and and own this Square I like
A4 I love a I love the threat of A4 and
the idea that then the D5 Square would
open up but hikaro also playing really
fast really well so yeah if the queen is
forced to retreat maybe hikaro plays A4
now oh no okay he prevents A4 in another
way by guarding the A4 Square Queen is
getting into trouble again the queen on
A6 I don't like it
yeah the Queen's being kicked around a
little
bit going to win the B6 back normal
square but the B6 Pawn yeah that was
just a
blunder I think B6 was just a blunder he
should
have should have tried to be okay and he
still has some of the advantages we
talked about right the D Pawn is weak
there's this nice Square on D5 but it's
not the most traditional or most um you
know the way that he would have liked to
have held on to those Center
squares that's for sure h
I like I think Ser had a comfortable
position but he must have blundered with
this queen B5 and then getting the queen
into trouble he had to give up the B
Pawn or blunder the B
Pawn Yeah indeed um there's some outside
threats maybe of the queen and Knight
pulling a Batman and Robin Duo and
getting an attack here I mean does the
Knight come into E3 now okay he doesn't
I'm thinking that might be an outside
shot at Sergey launching something nasty
on the king side but no AAR plays D5
okay take F4 yeah take F4 and and you
can still get some squares here if
you're if you're black yes some chances
because it's not so easy to put the C
Pawn I agree this hasn't been the
most accurate conversion Knight G3 now
threaten Knight E2 check and create
create a mess oh he goes backwards I
don't like that move yeah rookie he Los
a piece no yes he does he Los a piece it
is a bler no I did not like and he just
resigned and aaro did the the slight
shift the slight shift over to the left
everybody that means I knew it was
coming I was going to get that win no
but seriously I mean Knight to G3 would
have changed the day there Knight G3
instead of Knight E7 I think he
undertime pressure kind of went back
into trying to defend the C Pawn instead
of maintaining some aggressive
chances too passive okay well with that
though I think we're almost in
mathematical territory to be as much as
I hate to say it seven seven wins a
seven game Advantage here with only 14
minutes left on the clock is just
mathematically
improbable
um so hiar Nakamura is going to be the
one who's who's moving on into the next
round and uh he's certainly moving and
he is going to face the winner of the
match if I'm correct it's between vesley
so and Anish no no no that's magnus's
line Sorry I'm confusing the bracket uh
Fabiana Carana or H
Yan the winner of that match is going to
face
Hikaru indeed and and and that's the
that's the the next round as we see it
already hikara Nakamura will be moving
on after today I think mathematically we
can pretty much call it uh this has been
awesome but and don't go anywhere it's
not over yet we're still going to have
postmatch interviews with both the
players uh get their thoughts break down
how they how they saw this match going
and and what happened but you see AAR
Nakamura is going to be moving on the
three seed takes care of business he
will as we said take on the winner
between the six seed Fabi Carana and the
11 seed ho yon and that should be fun
that's not till August but that's going
to be a great one can't wait to see how
ho yon does in this format um I think
that I'm going to make a prediction I
think yon's match will be the most
watched match in the first round really
including Carlson I just think she's
she's such a Global star I think the
audience you know from her home country
obviously in China um I think that um I
think people can't wait I mean she's the
first female player we've had in this in
these events so that matchup between
Carana and yon in August make sure you
check the schedule everybody uh I I
anticipate that to be just a very very
highly viewed match I'm personally I
think I might be more excited about that
than any of the other first round
matchups can't wait to see what happens
there sorry to interrupt your excitement
Danny but everybody is shouting at us
that we should show the game because
it's going to be over we are showing the
games everybody calm down we're also
talking about other no no I I wasn't but
I'm just telling them to calm down um
yeah so this one is uh but still headed
in the direction that the point is the
match is just kind of mathematically Out
Of Reach but okay you're right it looks
like serg is doing well this game and
and maybe has a chance
to to hold G4 hikaro Caro gave the
slight nod there like ah okay number two
that was a Caro slight nod number two
um he's he he didn't see that idea
coming but I don't know that it's going
to matter I think that black is still in
the driver's seat here and and I mean
Sergey is lit literally living off the
increment in such a way that he just
can't do it it's just it's just too much
he lost on time again but the B3 point
would have fallen and that would have
created a bastor anyway for Hikaru he's
he's just nodding he's very confident
and he knows that this is already in his
pocket the match has won has been won by
hikaro still a few games left and as
Denny said stay here because we are
going to interview the players finally
you can hear that thoughts uh after
these how many hours of play by the way
is it already three it'll it'll be three
total it it's already been it's already
been 2 hours and 45 minutes we're into
the final kind of half hour here um so
yeah so we have a an eight game lead uh
the as as Mike told us the largest
Victory margin ever was a full 17 games
when KN when Carlson won 21 to4 um we
don't think that Hikaru will get to that
but maybe he's going after a record of
his own um but okay so this is this is
going to be how the first round matchup
goes Nakamura is going to have shown
that why he is a big favorite and uh
what else what else I think that I think
that Sergey you know started having some
good results there in the 3-2 as white
and
you know I don't I think we expected
hikaro to win the bullet but maybe maybe
you know if he had to do it again maybe
he would have taken a slightly different
opening strategy than those first few
games we saw I don't know yeah we shall
ask him about that because when he
switched to E4 he started winning games
he seemed to be more uh more successful
with his E4 repertoire and then he
switched back to D4
mhm yeah indeed
um oh oh once again an exchange because
after Knight C4 the D6 bomb was hanging
and now this is just a
fork yeah he's winning G2 yeah but he's
oh wow he's gonna win the ex no he's
going to go down a piece dead he's going
to go down a piece it it was a lot of
gun smoke a lot of gun smoke confused us
but really when it clears white is still
just up a piece just a piece up for
white and uh
maybe even sacked the queen here I
almost would have sacked the queen Just
for kicks and gigs but okay aaro wins
that one uh takes a yet another yet
another game from Sergey Goran now uh
with a nine game lead with nine minutes
remaining um we are we are again out of
the range there but I know people always
want to see the games but this is just
the opening so I'm going to talk a
little bit again generally about what it
is that we're doing here just to remind
everybody that we also have the uh you
know I haven't I haven't talked too much
about the prizes but here's the
breakdown of how it works in the first
round there's a total of $166,000
available through the eight matches to
the players um after just a few hours so
not that you know not the not the
biggest money not $100,000 per game but
for a couple hours pretty good money
there I take it and uh then then it's
based on win winning match percentage
but with every round it gets you know
the prices increase big time in terms of
what's available to them for for the win
and then in the final round we have
$5,000 to the winner and $5,000 split so
that's just one s one single round there
we have $10,000 in prizes for the final
four players so lots of fun there going
to be exciting to see and and uh
certainly it was a a worthy payday to
Sergey gregorians just to kind of get
here right just to get into this
position despite losing the m so and uh
he needs to win a few more games po you
know take a few hundred out of hi Caro's
pocket that's what he going for right
now he surely tries because he he knows
that any any extra point can give him
extra cash so there's a lot of
motivation even even when the match is
lost
right and he's better here though this
looks like a a a successful position
there for for white and hikaro
acknowledges it with his kind of
frustration although now the E5 Pawn
might fall but still looks like with
white having the bishop pair um and and
already in control over the defile here
we go it looks like this just should be
a one that one that one that goes the
the way of Sergey C6
now defend the work on the seventh ring
I like
C6 the point everybody is seeing ofus
pair of
knights so he goes for
C6 yeah I like it it's a great idea
because this way he will have a very
dangerous passone in case if Rook takes
D7 actually it was impossible to stop
that pass Pawn very nice followup E6
getting the bishop and The Rook to work
together here on the Square
C7 very nice and uh here we go what's he
gonna do B5 but now Knight D4 isn't he
dropping the pawn oh he Caro's got the
head Bob going he's got the head Bob
going could somebody get us a Caro
bobblehead will somebody please make
that and send it to me I mean serious I
need a hikaro bobble head you're and
they're like Danny you already have Fat
Heads like what is wrong with you I need
a bob head so I can do wouldn't that be
awesome you know bobblehead you just
bobblehead it that's what we're doing
that next I'm making a Caro bobblehead
it's happening note
to yeah so now that he has managed to
win the pass PA he should be able to
hold this it's a pawn up for black but
doubled pawns and against the pair of
Bishops you can you can still lose this
game if you're not playing with the most
precise
way Knight E5 that was a strong move cuz
it forced one of the Bishops off
yeah yeah he cares playing very well
obviously yeah but and now and now if
hikaro finds a way to get that Bishop
into an awkward position okay now he
kind of settles on trading trading the
pawn for Pawn without without trying to
put the bishop in a in a zwang of some
kind but this should just be a draw and
hikaro can decide how he wants to win
this match play another game or just
play a whole bunch of moves here and
take a whole bunch of time off the total
game clock m
only five minutes
do you know he might he might fool
around here for a little bit before
taking the
draw only 5 minutes and 30 seconds
remaining on the on for this match
although we will have one more 960 game
so that should be fun no matter what but
hikaro wins on time and the main reason
he should keep playing I guess is that
right now he's just he's he's running
down the clock on its opponent he won on
time that's just so I mean I mean of
course it it doesn't take credit away
from Hikaru this is a bullet game where
one second is the increment but Sergey
has lost several games on time by
now yep indeed and it's you know the one
second increment is enough if you're the
nice thing about it is as we said it
makes the speed chest format one where
if you're winning on the board you won't
lose because of the clock because those
guys can pre moove in a lot of those
cases and that one second makes a big
difference but you know if you're in a
bad position one second increment is not
really enough often to hold it right
it's just it's just too much um to to
have to think and so hik Caro's job is
to pose problems and make his opponent
think and and he's doing that as well as
anybody I guess probably who's not
Magnus Carlson right in terms of posing
problems for his opponents to to have to
solve yeah look at those head
movements is is it is it because of the
music is he Dancing Yeah I think he's I
think he's listening to music I think
he's just kind of rolling right now
whenever we mention something like that
he just disappears he's time
traveling he's time traveling right
now I don't know know he's not listening
to us he's already back no I mean I
would never listen to me while playing
chess games um yeah that would that
would be a bad idea for any player any
player
right including myself to listen to
myself while playing chess listening to
Danny wrench not on the top of your
to-do list um but
uh but no he just had to do a quick time
travel thing I think to make sure he
stayed up on
time okay there you go that's a nice
tactic Follow by Knight to G5 ouch
beautiful the knight's coming to G5
everybody if Rook F7 Knight G5 and
there's just uh too many problems here
you know you can play E6 and try to open
up where ways your pieces might
coordinate but likely White's going to
get enough ooh he doesn't even take it
and now the whole King side is opening
up KN G5 is threatening it was
threatening the move Knight E6 forking
the king and
queen hikaro is not giving up on that
idea he'd like to trade and then bring
that pony
in so he's going to take and after H G5
probably just back up the bishop and
save it somewhere like B1 and and
White's position is just just awesome
yeah this is once again hopeless for
Sergey
unfortunately um the match is not going
any better for him and it's not about
not losing the match I mean we knew that
he was going to lose the match after the
last few games but he should pick up
some more points from Hikaru right but
it's hard right psychologically I mean
you're kind of feel
just you know you're kind of beaten at
this point and and you feel like the
rest is just kind of history but yes it
is true there is you know there is money
on the line with every game that's for
sure um and uh once again he W on time
but the position was already already
lost for black
most of that money will be headed to the
American but we will talk to them
obviously we'll talk to Sergey about his
opening strategy and you know maybe he
didn't even have any time to prepare but
we'll ask him about his psychology there
um ask him how he felt about obviously
as the wheels came off if he felt
frustrated and didn't even have it to
play for more of those wins you know I'm
going to get we definitely got to get
hik Caro's thoughts on some of the other
matchups I'm curious who how hikaro
thinks the matchup between Fabian caran
and ho yon might go and some of you know
who he might who he might play in the
next round so um we'll have some fun
questions for these for these two as
soon as we're done with this match so
please don't go anywhere
everybody or go somewhere and get a
snack and come
back and Nakamura is dancing again he
was even singing I would swear that he
was
singing why not right yeah he's
celebrating already Zippity
Duda there he
goes um he's an Entertainer first aaro
understands that that chess's
entertainment um all right and so now we
have is in his contract is it in his
contract to dance yeah I don't think so
no we don't we don't require that I mean
we we just highly encourage it um but uh
no I mean it it's it's a a fun match
anyway um this will be the last game of
bullet we will see a chess 960 battle
for for kicks and gigs uh and then we
will we'll we'll see what the players
felt about the matchup and and then you
and I look forward to uh you know to
what's on the schedule next May 24th
between uh karakan and
Meer so this is the last bullet game and
the hikaro is not having any problems it
was the beginning of the bullet games
where he was playing not so well and
that was the moment when sty could have
taken advantage of the lack of uh
preciseness and confidence of Hikaru but
that second game since it since it
turned from an advantage of Sergey to a
loss uh I think that that was the
turning point in the bullet portion yeah
back breaker back breaker for sure and I
think that you know given hikaru's
reputation it would be un unfair to say
he wouldn't have pulled it together at
some point anyway cuz he's very very
good at bullet but yeah I agree that
psychologically the wheels come off and
it's often a game of momentum you know
they don't whoever starts winning
usually wins more um yes and so I agree
I think psychologically most the time
these players are closer in their chess
skills than sometimes the final score
reveals but uh but one side really gets
a hold of things and just kind of runs
away with it MH so we will have a chess
960 game right after this don't go
anywhere this should be
fun uh it looks like aaru is in the
driver's seat here because that's a
queen right and yeah and
uh again he has thrown in the tow and
with it the final chess 960 game starts
we
are we are in Fun mode now this should
be interesting what do we got here we
got Bishops on the
diagonal
um we got Bishops on the diagonal we got
Kings on the C
file so once again I'm always confused
by cing in this position you CLE by
removing the B8 Knight and then and the
rook and the King well you have to
remove the d8 Knight too the squares of
wherever you would finish the final
squares where you would finish in terms
of castling traditionally must be
open okay everything about castles
basically is like a classical game other
than the starting positions of the
pieces so you still you have to have all
those squares removed they can't be
occupied um you know you can't be going
through check you can't have mve your
king or Rook but but yeah so if if the
if the Knight on D1 moved right now for
example for white W
Castle I see some of you guys here in
the chat are making fun of Danny they
saying last just to bring up the
bracket because they they don't really
like to see the brackets but you should
believe us that not everybody has been
here for all these hours so we are
showing it from time and again because
some of you are new and you should know
what this is all about that's right plus
you're all watching the games yourself
in the live server anyway aren't you so
you know stop your
complaining uh but anyway tweet us your
pictures it is your really your last
chance to tweet tweet us the hashtag
speechs and let Anna let Anna decide who
has the most interesting stuff for us I
feel like if we get so many people
involved maybe maybe hit me up later an
and let me know maybe we'll give away
some more Diamond memberships if we have
be so cool so please please please then
I don't have to announce it right now
but we can give us give out some more
maybe yeah we'll just contact everybody
and let them know those who were most
involved thank you um so guys keep
tweeting because we may have like 20
prices somebody's like you know trying
to pull together the most elaborate
setup ever right now um but okay so
Sergey is uh a little bit worse here
Black's Rook is on the on the second
rank but you know some decent drawing
chances once again this looks completely
normal uh not not a chess 960
game
um doesn't look that way
anyway we've got we've got some new
stats from Mike and he's saying that it
will be the second largest margin of
Victory ever unless Sergey wins the
final game yeah and it doesn't look like
he's on Pace for doing that um so the
this is a currently a 12-point victory
yeah I believe currently the second
largest ever was one where I think maybe
Nakamura beat Wesley so by 11 games
there was a um in a in a previous Blitz
Death Match before we were before we
really organized the league here that
kind of has it all together but um so if
I'm not mistaken I think that that was
the 11 game Victory by nakor over so
might have been that match or maybe
there's another one Mike has all these
stats oh hikaro beat mvl by 11 as well
and just like that hikaro has achieved
the the second largest margin of Victory
ever last game so the final score
is the final score is 20 a half to 7 and
a half we have uh we have uh a score of
20 half to 7 and a half as soon as it's
updated at the end of the one-1 portion
and we will be bringing on both players
for for some postmatch interviews in
just a moment in fact I think I think
both players are coming on now are they
with us now can you both hear us guys
yeah I can hear you guys
Sergey I think he cannot hear us yet are
you with us Sergey I think maybe his his
microphone is he's wearing a chess.com
shirt that's a sexy shirt there nice
ciry I didn't even know you had a
chess.com shirt did I get you that or
did you just buy
it can't wait to hear him he doesn't
hear it he's sporting a chess.com Polo
we got to we got to love that
unfortunately it didn't bring him enough
luck here today against you hikaro this
was a this was a um a dominant
performance
congratulations um and uh certainly uh
you you
it started out a little slow maybe can
we get your thoughts on that obviously
the F minute portion was was kind of
tough maybe we're missing some chances
to convert but um when did you feel you
really kind of got your rhythm going and
and saw the match headed your direction
are you talking to me yeah um I mean I I
would say that I didn't play very well
up until the bullet perhaps or very end
of three minute but um I think uh I
think when I I didn't lose that fourth
game I wanted say in the in the five
minute section after that um once I got
like the two game lead I never really
felt that it was in danger but um yeah
overall Sergey played quite well he was
quite solid I thought um but then yeah
on the bullet I mean was just a little
bit a little bit quicker than he was
right a lot of games lost on time there
Sergey are you with us now can we can
you got your mic
on yes yes no oh there you are sorry no
it's okay it's okay um we had a few
questions obviously a tough matchup
taking on hikara Nakamura you knew that
coming in right he's he's pretty good at
this at this online Blitz and bullet
thing um but but where did you feel
maybe your best chances were in the
match and and um if you had it to do
over again some some of the games that
maybe you thought maybe could have gone
differently okay probably I should try
to do it a bit faster than I did this is
a BL games and okay I try to do my best
but uh it's clear what hear is just
faster and have another kind of
processor in this sense Ann I had a
question for you about your opening
approach to start the match so I'll let
her take it yeah we were curious about
you switching from 1 D4 to 1 E4 and then
switching back can you explain what what
was your preparation for the match
because you had only two days to prepare
for Hikaru that's not much
time okay honestly I didn't prepare it
so much and before we already played
quite a lot of games hikaro and chesc so
we played a lot of these Berlin end
games and I just wanted to try something
another position as well because it
would be a bit boring if we would just
play Berlin like
this we we appreciate that we appreciate
that um but overall uh you know you
defended really well there were a lot of
games you know to start you were down
the exchange in a couple games that you
managed to hold and and um with the
longer time controls you seem to be able
to to find resourceful defensive moves
but you just you know just felt like
over time hikaro was just that much
faster you couldn't keep up lost a lot
of games on time
right yes I tried to to do what position
is L to me try to different well it you
dominated this entire month on chess.com
I was your what was your idea of playing
every qualifier were you trying to deny
other people's spots even though you
were the first one to earn it or you
just wanted to get some more
money I'm sure yes but
uh no you are speaking quite good but
I'm not so good English oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm I'm speaking too fast I'm
sorry um I wanted to just congratulate
you on your month you were the first one
to qualify and you you played very very
well in every single one of our title
Tuesdays so I was kind of teasing you
but just giving you a congratulations
even though today was a tough match
thank you thank you very much yes you
were the most consistent player because
you won the first qualifier and then you
kept on playing every Tuesday and
finishing at the top of the standing so
we thought that was very
impressive hey Carl You' played a few of
these oh sorry sorry
Sergey I was gonna
say go
ahead go ahead Sergey my fault I'll shut
up
no okay awkward
um hey CaRu uh you've played a few of
these let me ask you something are you
more you get a little nervous when
you're playing somebody like uh mvl
somebody who you've played you know
several times in these big matches or is
it is it do you get a little bit nervous
when you're playing one of the
challengers someone who qualifies maybe
somebody who haven't played in this
format before um I mean I think nervous
is the wrong word um I mean I think if
I'm if I'm playing
Maxim um I I'm a little bit um sharper I
would say I mean I I don't mean that I'm
not not sharp but you know somehow it
feels like when I play the slightly
lower ranked players I feel like maybe
half point one point is not the end of
the world and I can make it up somewhere
whereas against Maxim I mean I feel like
every every half Point matters I tend to
be a little bit sharper when I play
against him because like okay even the
start of this match um I think the
second or third game I mean I had this
uh this um this end game up the exchange
and I mean it should be winning quite
easily and I found a way to uh totally
totally butchered and ended in a draw um
but uh but but yeah I mean it's you know
everyone's good and it's just trying to
not get behind early and then I figure I
can find my rhythm
later looking at the uh the remainder of
this of the event you're going to be
playing the winner of either Fabiana
Carana or Hoon I told Anna I thought
that that match with ho youon playing
would be probably one of the most viewed
ones obviously she's a pretty Global
super superstar but just speaking from
your chess perspective I'm going to ask
both of you who do you see as the
favorite there uh Fabiano not as much of
an online you know Blitz and bullet
specialist as someone like you or Magnus
Carlson so how do you how do you see
that matchup going down between Fabian
or hoon and who would you rather
play um okay I guess I'll start uh I
mean obviously both of them are quite
strong uh but I mean I I certainly would
like to see who uh who Ean win the match
I mean it's uh it's always good to see
the the essentially the Women's World
Champion uh competing and and doing
quite well against uh all of us elite
players so I would root for her but I
think I think actually Fabiano is
probably like um I don't know like 7030
favorite is my guess okay uh Sergey what
and what are your thoughts on that
matchup so po what F ano is favorite in
this match but everything is possible I
don't know especially last part is one
minute game I don't know how good is H
find in this stuff
right if you had it to do over again now
that the match is over if you if you had
your pick of of somebody to play who
wasn't Hikaru out of the other three
Magnus kakan or Maxim who would it have
been okay OB was that I would be happy
to play with world champion it
is lifetime chance but
yes cool well that's a that's a pretty
good perspective there well we thank you
both for being here sorry if the
questions seem last question because uh
we thought Hikaru you were listening to
some music and of course that's always
something that we want to know what kind
of music it was yeah I was just
listening to some rock music so like I
think at the start of the match I I had
this problem of turning off the sound uh
when you guys were speaking so I had to
like go go get my phone and start
playing music off of it instead of
instead of this so it was a a Str
strange experience but um I was
listening to a Canadian group I was
listening to the uh the arel which is a
form of
rock nice that's good to know we should
we should also write that down and put
it on our
playlist well thank you both for being
here uh really appreciate you sticking
around after such a long long match uh
you guys are both both awesome lots of
fans and uh congratulations again to you
Sergey for having such an awesome month
and and getting this far and
congratulations to you H Caro moving on
to the next round and uh we'll probably
see you back Sergey next year if we hold
qualifiers because your your persistence
makes me think you'd probably qualify
again I hope congratulations to both of
you thank you thanks
guys all right
we good yep you guys are good go
ahead all right well we've lost our
we've lost our players but uh Anna
before we before we bring the show to a
close let's um let's talk quickly one
more time about the thing no one wants
to talk about the schedules the
schedules of the match the uh the next
match coming up obviously is once again
one more time on May 24th uh between um
yorg Meyer and Sergey kakan and then of
course again on May 25th so those are
the matches that we'll be seeing next
and uh Anna this this was a lot of fun
uh what else should we remind everybody
about before we go is I guess it's too
late to fill out your bracket for most
of you I get to kind of cheat but who
knows maybe we'll let some L entes come
in make sure you a bracket of course you
should you should still use the hashtag
speed chess on Twitter um maybe a last
minute photo can still make it into our
picture contest because now we will look
at the tweets with Danny and we will
decide who are the winners at least
three winners but I will convince him to
get maybe 10 I don't know if I can
manage but I will try to do my
best all right well membership to many
of you that that I can promise all right
we're going to let everybody go as uh
the the our our other partners have
already left us and so um we will thank
you everybody for being here hiar
Nakamura once again moves on in the
first round
on